et nous accueillons aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de nos auditions budgétaires sur
le PLF 2023 monsieur ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre nous avions eu le
plaisir de vous auditionner peu après
votre nomination en juillet dernier
nos échanges avaient été riche
témoignant de l'intérêt que porte notre
commission pour les sujets liés à
l'éducation et à la jeunesse
l'ordre du jour des prochaines séances
du Sénat témoignent d'ailleurs de la
diversité des sujets relevants de votre
champ de compétence ils sont ainsi
inscrits un débat sur l'enseignement
professionnel à l'initiative du groupe
des Républicains un autre celui sur le
bilan de parcoursup à la demande du
groupe CRCE ou encore l'examen d'une
proposition de loi portant sur la
titularisation des accompagnements des
accompagnants pardon d'élèves en
situation de handicap et des assistants
d'éducation présentés
par Sylvie Robert et les membres du
groupe socialiste dont nous discuterons
ensemble le 8 décembre prochain
aujourd'hui c'est sur le projet de loi
de finance pour 2023 que nous avons
l'opportunité d'échanger
or enseignement agricole je rappelle que
le budget de la mission enseignement
scolaire et de 80,8 milliards d'euros
58,8 milliards d'euros si on exclut la
contribution aux pensions de l'État
c'est la première mission du budget
général après le remboursement et les
dégrèvements par rapport au projet de
loi de finances pour 2022 les crédits
sont en hausse de plus de 4,5 milliards
d'euros cette augmentation est à saluée
même si nos points de vigilance sont
nombreux nous aurons l'occasion de vous
les exprimer les questions de notre
rapporteur pour avis Jacques gros Perrin
et de nos collègues vous permettront
sans doute de justement de les constater
lors de notre dernière rencontre vous
aviez indiqué vouloir construire votre
action autour de cinq thématiques les
savoirs fondamentaux l'égalité des
chances et la réduction des inégalités
le bien-être des élèves l'environnement
et l'écologie par l'institution scolaire
et enfin la revalorisation des
enseignants comment comptez-vous
comptez-vous mobiliser le budget allouer
à votre ministère au profit de ces
différentes thématiques en ce qui
concerne la revalorisation des
enseignants nous souhaitions
souhaiterions avoir plus d'informations
sur les nouvelles missions que les
enseignants pourraient être amenés à
exercer dans le cadre du Pacte annoncé
par le président de la République
la Direction de l'évaluation et de la
prospective et de la performance de
votre ministère il y a en effet de
publier mi-octobre une autre relevant
que la moitié des enseignants déclare
travailler plus de 43 heures par semaine
quelle nouvelle mission facultative
pourrait leur être confiée pouvez-vous
nous pouvez vous faire un point sur le
calendrier des rencontres prévues avec
les syndicats sur ce sujet enfin dans
son discours doutes 2022 devant les
recteurs le président de la République
annonçait la mise en place d'un fond
d'innovation pédagogique nous débattons
régulièrement au sein de notre
commission sur l'opportunité de donner
plus d'autonomie aux enseignants et aux
établissements aussi nous sommes
intéressés par les informations que vous
pourrez nous transmettre sur la mise en
place de ce fond son montant et les
projets qui pourraient être qui
pourraient contribuer à soutenir
monsieur le ministre je vous propose
dans un propos liminaire de nous
présenter les principales orientations
de votre budget après quoi je céderais
la parole
notre rapporteur pour les crédits de
l'enseignement scolaire puis également
Gérard Longuet qui est rapporteur de la
commission des finances puis un membre
de chaque groupe politique je rappelle
que cette audition est captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
monsieur le ministre je vous donne la
parole
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ce projet de loi de
finances démontre notre détermination à
faire de l'éducation une des priorités
de ce nouveau quinquennat à travers des
réformes ambitieuses portées vous l'avez
dit par une augmentation forte et même
inédite du budget de l'Éducation
nationale cette progression s'inscrit
dans une dynamique de croissance
constante depuis 2017 mais ce budget-ci
constitue une réelle rupture dans
l'ampleur de l'augmentation budgétaire
proposée et dans l'ambition qualitative
qui est portée le PLF 2023 prévoit ainsi
un budget de 59,7 milliards d'euros pour
l'éducation nationale ce sont 3,7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires soit
une croissance de 6,5% par rapport à
2022 il s'agit d'un investissement
massif au bénéfice de la réussite de
tous les élèves c'est à dire en réalité
un investissement indispensable pour
l'avenir de notre pays cet effort
budgétaire permet de mettre en musique
les priorités que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion d'énoncer la première
priorité
vous l'avez indiqué Président c'est la
revalorisation des enseignants et c'est
naturellement elle qui compte le plus
dans ce budget 2023 cette revalorisation
est le préalable indispensable à toute
action de refondation et de
transformation de l'école il s'agit de
reconnaître l'investissement
l'engagement sans faille des enseignants
au service de leurs élèves trop
longtemps leur dévouement que je tiens à
rappeler il y a saluer dans cette
enceinte n'a pas été
rétribué à sa juste valeur le Sénat a
récemment consacré un rapport très clair
et très précis sur la situation des
professeurs français par rapport à leur
homologues européens et ce rapport
soulignait à juste titre la nécessité
d'un sursaut pour éviter une crise
profonde du recrutement
ce sursaut ou plutôt ce choc
d'attractivité vous le trouvez dans ce
budget une enveloppe totale de 935
millions d'euros et consacrés à la
revalorisation des enseignants pour 2023
c'est d'autant plus considérable qu'elle
entrera en vigueur en septembre 2023 et
que cette somme couvre donc les quatre
derniers mois de l'année
cette revalorisation est composée de
deux parties une part inconditionnelle
et une part dite pacte perçue à la
condition de l'exercice de nouvelles
missions qui seront définies dans le
cadre de la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales qui s'est
ouverte il y a un mois le 3 octobre
la part inconditionnel donc dispose
d'une enveloppe de 635 millions d'euros
au PLF 2023 ce qui représentera en année
courantes
1,9 milliards d'euros
concentré sur la première partie de
carrière cette part permettra de casser
le faux plat qui caractérise la
progression de salaire sur cette période
en milieu de période de carrière en
prolongeant les efforts réalisés dans le
cadre du Grenelle de l'éducation et de
la hausse du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires cette revalorisation
permet d'aboutir à une hausse totale
moyenne de 10%
cela nous permettra de réaliser
l'engagement du président de la
République ne plus avoir d'enseignants
payer moins de 2000 euros net par mois
nous devons donner envie aux jeunes de
s'engager dans les carrières du
professorat et nous devons les soutenir
au cours de leur première année
d'exercice un moment où les besoins
financiers sont importants les
personnels situés en fin de carrière ne
sont toutefois pas oubliés puisqu'un
effort complémentaire se traduira par
l'amélioration de l'accès au grade fino
le hors classe et la classe
exceptionnelle dans le cadre de mesure
interministérielles qui sont
actuellement en discussion
par ailleurs la revalorisation passera
par un nouveau pacte proposé à tous les
enseignants qui offrira une hausse
supplémentaire de rémunération à la
condition d'exercer de nouvelles
missions qui sont parfois
je reviendrai sur votre question
président qui sont parfois réalisées
sans être pleinement valorisé sans
préjugés des conclusions de la
concertation la formation hors temps
d'enseignement la mise en oeuvre de
projets pédagogiques le suivi
individualisé des élèves l'aide à
l'orientation ou encore le remplacement
de courte durée font partie des missions
qui pourraient faire l'objet de ces
rémunérations complémentaires c'est un
levier indispensable pour permettre la
transformation en profondeur de notre
école
ce dispositif est doté d'une enveloppe
de 300 millions d'euros sur les quatre
derniers mois de 2023 l'équivalent en
année pleine à compter de 2024 évoluera
en fonction du rythme des adhésions
opaques qu'on ne peut pas complètement
prévoir à ce stade
l'ensemble des enseignants y compris
ceux des lycées professionnels mais
aussi les enseignants des lycées
agricoles bénéficieront de ces
revalorisations
d'autres professionnels de l'éducation
nationale or enseignant bénéficieront
également de mesures de revalorisation
pour traiter les enjeux spécifiques
d'attractivité et de reconnaissance de
certains métiers de l'éducation
nationale je pense par exemple au
personnel de la filière
médico-sociale qui joue un rôle
déterminant auprès des élèves les
personnels administratifs ou les
conseillers pédagogiques sont également
concernés au total une enveloppe de près
de 66 millions d'euros sera mobilisé
pour l'ensemble de ces mesures
catégorielles
le deuxième axe fort de ce budget c'est
la réussite de tous les élèves
budgétairement cette priorité se traduit
par deux actions en premier lieu la
poursuite de l'amélioration du taux
d'encadrement dans le premier degré et
sa stabilisation dans le second degré en
seconde lieu la prolongation
l'engagement des dispositifs pour la
réussite des élèves tels que les
dédoublements en Rep le plafonnement à
24 des classes de primaire horaire ou le
développement des classes ULIS
l'effort sur les taux d'encadrement se
traduit par une reprise partielle de la
baisse démographique que nous
connaissons déjà et qui va s'accentuer
dans les prochaines années en disant je
vous rappelle que la France est passée
de d'une moyenne de 830 000 naissances
par an à 738
000 naissances c'est un une baisse tout
à fait considérable et après justement
une baisse de 300000 élèves sur les 5
dernières années nous prévoyons une
baisse de 500 000 élèves sur la période
2022 2027 cette évolution se traduit par
la diminution constatée de 58 000 élèves
à la rentrée 2022 il est prévisions pour
l'année 2023 2024 atteignent presque 100
000 élèves en moins
je me permets de rappeler que les
prévisions que j'avais données au mois
de juillet ne tenait pas compte était un
peu plus négative pour la baisse des
élèves pour l'année qui s'est écoulé
mais elle tenait pas compte des quelques
20000 élèves Ukrainiens qui ont été
scolarisés et donc il y a une petite
compensation l'année dernière
si nous répercussions complètement cette
baisse sur le nombre d'enseignants cela
reviendrait à supprimer 5000 postes
d'enseignants en limitant cette baisse à
2000 postes nous poursuivons l'effort
pluriannuel sur les taux d'encadrement
puisque dans le premier degré nous
sommes passés d'une moyenne de 23,6
enfants par classe en 2016 à 21,6 en
2022 nous prévoyons de faire baisser ce
chiffre en 2023 pour atteindre 21,3
élèves par classe en moyenne
dans ce cadre je réaffirme que la baisse
des effectifs enseignants tiendra compte
des enjeux liés à la ruralité en
conformité avec l'engagement du
président de la République aucune
fermeture d'école n'interviendra sans
l'accord des mers
au-delà des dispositions budgétaires du
PLF la réussite des élèves passera aussi
par des réformes structurantes comme
celle du collège sur laquelle nous
travaillons activement il s'agit aussi
de la réforme de la voie professionnelle
annoncée par le président de la
République qui a souhaité que celle-ci
soit construite dans le cadre d'une
large concertation qui a débuté
le troisième point c'est la réussite de
tous les élèves à propos de la réussite
de tous les élèves c'est la poursuite de
l'école inclusive l'école inclusive
demeure une priorité pour le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse et pour le gouvernement
4000 postes d'aosh ont été créés à la
rentrée 2022 4000 postes seront créés à
la rentrée 2023 cette hausse continue
que nous assumons ne peut cependant pas
être la seule réponse aux besoins des
élèves a besoin particulier
la hausse des notifications que nous ne
maîtrisons pas puisqu'elle dépendent des
MDPH et beaucoup plus rapide que celle
du nombre d'Ash surtout les fortes
divergences entre départements les
situations de saturation dans certaines
classes les difficultés de recrutement
d'aesh dans certains bassins nous impose
de réfléchir plus globalement à la
situation et de construire ce que nous
appelons un acte 2 de l'école inclusive
de manière à répondre de manière
pertinente et soutenable à la situation
de chaque enfant tout en garantissant
dans le temps cette école inclusive en
particulier d'un point de vue budgétaire
l'objectif de la réforme est claire que
chaque enfant soit correctement
accompagné en fonction de ses besoins
nous nous mettons donc en ordre de
bataille pour que des propositions
concrètes puissent être inscrites à
l'ordre du jour de la conférence
nationale du handicap qui aura lieu au
printemps 2023 et je serai heureux le
moment venu si vous le souhaitez devenir
de revenir vous en parler
une démarche de concertation a été
engagée par la première ministre dans le
cadre du comité interministériel du
handicap le 8 octobre 2022 au vu des
conclusions de cette concertation nous
ferons évoluer les outils de l'école
inclusive ce sont des évolutions qui
bénéficieront aux ESH puisque dans ce
cadre nous souhaitons définir les
modalités qui leur permettront
d'atteindre si tel et leur choix un
temps plein de 35 heures en partenariat
avec les collectivités territoriales
cela représentera également un progrès
pour les élèves en situation de handicap
la situation matérielle des aesh est
ainsi un sujet majeur d'attention dans
ce chantier et nous privilégions pour
cela l'option des 35 heures pour
améliorer leur rémunération néanmoins
comme vous l'avez peut-être noté dans le
cadre des débats à l'Assemblée nationale
une préoccupation
légitime s'est exprimée vis-à-vis de ces
personnels essentiels pour le
fonctionnement de l'école inclusive
fragilisée par le contexte
inflationniste que nous connaissons nous
avons donc décidé avec la première
ministre de retenir une proposition
d'amendements actant une revalorisation
de 10% des aesh à partir du 1er
septembre 2023 selon le même calendrier
que celui des enseignants
80 millions d'euros supplémentaires sont
ainsi prévus pour financer cette
revalorisation pour laquelle le gage a
été levé
cette revalorisation s'ajoute à
l'enveloppe de 74 millions d'euros
initialement prévu dans le budget qui
permettra à ces personnel ainsi qu'auxed
de percevoir la prime réplus lorsque
bien entendu
leur affectation les y autorise
en quatrième point j'ai également
souhaité à travers ce budget donné corps
à la priorité que j'ai fixée en matière
de lutte contre les inégalités sociales
et territoriales
de fait la lutte contre les inégalités
scolaires est au fondement de notre
capacité à faire société c'est aussi une
condition du bon fonctionnement de
l'éducation nationale et de
l'amélioration globale de nos résultats
pour cela nous développons les
dispositifs de soutien aux familles les
plus fragiles via la hausse des bourses
plus 4% à partir de la rentrée 2022 je
parle des bourses scolaires ce qui
représente un total de 835 millions
d'euros en 2023
les établissements sont parieurs
encouragés à améliorer l'utilisation de
leur fonds sociaux qui sont actuellement
sous consommés
je suis également très vigilant
vis-à-vis des inégalités territoriales
et en ce sens l'expérimentation des
contrats locaux d'accompagnement les
classes et des territoires éducatifs
ruraux sera étendu près de 9 millions
d'euros sont inscrits au PLF 2023 sur
ces deux dispositifs
amélioration du niveau scolaire
réduction des inégalités bien-être c'est
priorités se retrouveront dans le fond
d'innovation pédagogique qui sera dotée
en 2023 de 150 millions d'euros pour les
4 derniers mois de l'année 2023 ce font
est une vraie nouveauté puisqu'il va
permettre de financer tous les projets
pédagogiques innovants portés par les
équipes éducatives qui seront issues des
débats engagés dans le cadre du Conseil
national de la refondation qui a été
lancé par le Président de la République
le 8 septembre dernier et si vous le
souhaitez je serai heureux de vous
entretenir sur ces concertations qui
sont lancées depuis le 3 octobre les
projets bénéficiant d'un soutien
financier financier pourront être très
divers dès lors qu'il vis à améliorer la
réussite des élèves
en nous fondant sur l'expérience en nous
fondant mais sans la dupliquer sur
l'expérience conduite à Marseille nous
préparons le déploiement d'un dispositif
ambitieux dans son volume et novateur
dans son fonctionnement puisqu'il sera
pleinement déconcentré et proche du
terrain
ce nouveau fond qui viendra abonder
notre budget à partir d'un transfert de
crédit de la mission investir pour la
France de 2030 permettra par exemple de
financer des projets autour du
développement durable de l'inclusion des
savoirs fondamentaux ou de l'arc ou de
l'éducation artistique et culturelle le
tout sans mise en concurrence des écoles
et établissements les uns contre les
autres et dans un esprit de confiance
fait aux équipes pédagogiques
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
je vous rends la parole président merci
monsieur le ministre et sans plus tarder
je vais donner la parole à Jacques
Grosperrin qui est rapporteur de la
commission
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
culture éducation communication sur les
crédits qui vous concernent merci
président merci monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues alors derrière les
chiffres bien sûr il y a des politiques
et derrière les politiques il y a la
vision que vous avez
de l'éducation nationale et les réponses
que vous ferez aujourd'hui que vous nous
ferez aujourd'hui
sans présager du
de l'aspect positif ou l'acceptation des
crédits ou non acceptation des crédits
même si notre notre vénérable collègue
Gérard Longuet à Albi un avis en
commission des finances la commission de
l'éducation et en tout cas dans
l'hémicycle les choses peuvent peut-être
être différentes elles seront
dépendantes essentiellement donc
des réponses que vous aurez ici et dans
l'hémicycle moi ce que je voudrais vous
dire je vous remercie pour vos propos et
vous dire que la préparation de la
dernière rentrée scolaire a été marquée
par des résultats
inquiétants des concours de 2022 chute
du nombre de candidats plus
particulièrement dans le premier degré
baisse du nombre de lauréats
augmentation sans précédent du nombre de
postes non pourvu dans le premier comme
dans le second degré on sait qu'il y a
eu des difficultés de double recrutement
les concours de recrutement 2022 montre
une évaporation des candidats qui va
selon moi au-delà des conséquences
mécaniques du niveau de diplôme exigé
depuis cette année nous devrons suivre
avec vigilance ces concours de 2023 pour
voir si le nombre de candidats connaît
une amélioration une fois que tous les
candidats potentiels auront franchi le
cap du Master exigé pour concourir donc
vous avez expliqué le PLF 2023 qui
traduit en effet des efforts très
significatifs pour revaloriser la
rémunération les rémunérations des
enseignants ici le notamment les jeunes
vous aviez de d'attractivité ce sont des
masses budgétaires qui sont
significatives
nous espérons que les fiches de paie
seront à la hauteur des besoins d'autant
que vous l'avez fort bien dit nous
partons de loin les salaires des
débutants sont bas a priori pour les
jeunes titulaires de Master 2 il est
certain pour produire des effets c'était
pour financier devrait être poursuit
pendant de nombreuses années à la
lecture des différents documents que
j'ai ici vous avez confirmé 2000 euros
par mois début de carrière ici le
salaire des enseignants jusqu'à 25% de
hausse donc vous mettez en tout cas vous
promettez une revalation une
revalorisation pardon historique
ce sera ma première question parce que
revalorisation historique sur les 935
millions d'euros vous nous avez parlé
donc de 635 millions qui seront pour
cette revalorisation et les 300 millions
qui sont provisionnés de manière moins
précise vous n'avez parlé de de
réflexion en tout cas que vous avez
syndicaux est-ce que ça s'appuiera
essentiellement sur le bon notariat nous
aimerions avoir quelques informations
lorsque vous nous dites qu'on peut très
bien penser que pour un professeur avec
quelques années d'ancienneté on a
jusqu'à 25% donc augmentation est-ce
qu'il y aura des contreparties qui
seront fixés par rapport à cela en tout
cas la profession a besoin de réponse le
deuxième point c'est sur la crise
actuelle du recrutement qui tient pas
uniquement en tout cas compte ou
nécessairement aux rémunérations mais
que c'était fort financier ne suffira
peut-être pas renverser en tout cas
c'est cette tendance on le voit dans les
pays étrangers qui a des difficultés qui
viennent surtout dans les conditions
d'exercice du métier qui sont difficiles
et qui se sont dégradées au fil du temps
particulièrement pour les enseignants en
tout cas qui se trouvent dans des
situations difficiles que ce soit
l'éducation prioritaire c'est pas ou
peut-être territoire peut-être un peu
délaissé
nous avons un symptôme qui qui apparaît
moi qui apparaît qui n'est pas nouveau
mais en tout cas qui s'accélère c'est
celui des démissions on peut minimiser
en disant que ça correspond à moins d'un
pour cent des effectifs parce que c'est
une vraie armée l'éducation nationale
avec ses 10 millions d'élèves les 100
millions d'enseignants c'est certains
pourraient dire que c'est une armée très
forte en tout cas plus importante que
l'armée russe son époque glorieuse en
tout cas
mais on peut dire aussi que les
démissions ont doublé entre 2013 et 2016
passant de 516 à 1002 en tout cas dans
le cadre du premier degré mais surtout
ce qui est ce qui nous inquiète c'est
que les démissionnaires sont jeunes 20%
au moins de 29 ans et ils le font
surtout en début de carrière parce qu'on
note que 30% des élèves stagiaires en
tout cas des élèves des stagiaires
partent un peu plus tôt donc c'est ma
deuxième question c'est votre sentiment
sur ces démissions qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez faire comment vous pouvez agir
comme je vous l'ai dit des chiffres il y
a des zones des les hommes il y a des
politiques et enfin le recrutement des
contractuels qui a été important cette
année on a vu que le job dating avait
quatre jours de formation non demeure
pas en tout cas que ces personnels
apportent souvent plus notamment dans le
segment professionnel et sans eux cette
rentrée aurait été à mon avis
certainement plus complexe j'aurais pu
vous parler la faible attractivité de
certains territoires j'aurais pu vous
parler de la mobilité géographique avec
les véritables problèmes des enseignants
du second degré qui pose des difficultés
mais j'aimerais enfin pour ma troisième
question c'est revenir sur la tractivité
du métier d'enseignant et sur la
formation initiale et continue est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas imaginer que les 300
millions provisionnés permettraient ou
ne pourraient-ils pas permettre
justement ces enseignants du premier
degré qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'être
délesté en quelque sorte de ce de leur
classe de pouvoir les payer au moment où
il prendrait cette formation continue
pendant les vacances scolaires est-ce
que ça serait une idée à mon avis
intéressante et puis enfin une dernière
question Président c'est sur le fond
d'innovation pédagogique vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure des 500 millions
quinquennat 150 millions donc en 2023
parce que c'est septembre octobre
novembre vous nous avez dit que c'était
sur le programme investir pour la France
moi je m'inquiète parce que certains
syndicats d'ailleurs nous ont posé la
question sur le canal par lequel se font
pour être versés aux établissements du
premier degré qui aurait droit
d'autant que ces difficultés d'ailleurs
partagées pour les établissements
publics du premier degré donc quelle est
la base juridique et quelle est la ligne
budgétaire qui permettra de faire cela
en tout cas d'y répondre donc
clarification
salariale que faire par rapport au
démission attraction du métier et enfin
font d'innovation pédagogique sa base
juridique et Céline budgétaires je vous
remercie
merci Gérard longuerre à porteur spécial
de la commission des finances oui merci
monsieur le Président de me donner la
parole je voudrais saluer monsieur le
ministre et saluer mes excellents
collègues de la Commission de ces
agriculturelle et en particulier votre
rapporteur agroperen qui est un ami et
dont nous partageons les préoccupations
je voudrais d'abord dire que sur le plan
du climat je rapporte ce budget depuis
10 ans et j'observe une rationalité
nouvelle dans les échanges à la fois sur
les résultats scolaires et
incontestablement les classements
internationaux ont permis
parfois en les refroidissant d'avoir des
échanges plus rationnels sur la qualité
de notre enseignement dont nous avons
toujours tendance à penser qu'il est
exceptionnel mais dans les résultats et
les comparaisons
organisées aujourd'hui rationnellement
montre que ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
et que nous avons été parfois rattrapés
par d'autres pays qui ont fait des
efforts significatifs cette dimension
des comparaisons internationales permet
de mieux échanger et de surmonter
d'ailleurs des divisions politiques pour
revenir à l'essentiel
le succès de nos jeunes et les
perspectives qui leur sont offertes par
cet enseignement
la deuxième observation c'est que la
commission des finances qui n'a pas les
mêmes responsabilités que la Commission
d'affaires culturelle s'en est tenu au
chiffre et nous avons regardé d'une
façon assez systématique en effet la
rémunération de nos enseignants et les
choix salariaux qui ont été faits par
l'Éducation nationale d'une façon
informelle mettant avec une tendance
presque inexorable continu depuis
les débuts de la Cinquième République
pour fixer une date sans remonter
évidemment à Jules Ferry c'est un autre
sujet et il apparaît très clairement que
le primaire a toujours été
moins bien traité que le secondaire et
que l'ancienneté a toujours été
privilégiée je dirais à l'effort donc
j'ai des questions extrêmement pratiques
à vous poser monsieur le ministre la
première c'est comment ressentez-vous
ces inégalités dans
l'accès aux fonctions d'enseignants
métiers d'enseignant selon la discipline
que l'on a choisi il y a une très forte
inégalité de l'offre et de la demande
d'enseignant offre de poste Demande par
l'inscription concours et la présence
effective au concours selon les
disciplines ce n'est pas complètement
anormal vous en connaissez la raison il
y a des disciplines qui sont
concurrencées par d'autres débouchés il
y a des disciplines qui sont peu
concurrencées par d'autres débouchés
dans l'économie de marché par exemple et
qui par conséquent sont sans doute moins
contraints
cette inégalité par discipline elle se
double d'une égalité territoriale c'est
compliqué d'ailleurs cette inégalité
territoriale mais pour simplifier il y a
la réalité du coup de la vie qui n'est
pas le même dans
sur le territoire français et je ne
retiendrai au nom de la commission des
finances que cette inégalité à partir du
coût de la vie il y en a d'autres mais
c'est plutôt à la commission
d'afficulturelle ou la commission
d'aménagement territoire de les évoquer
comment imaginez-vous de enfin
premièrement acceptez-vous ce diagnostic
de l'inégalité selon le coût de la vie
de chaque région de France et si oui
quelles conséquences en tirez-vous
je reviens maintenant sur deux sujets
d'actualité ouvertes par des
déclarations du président de la
République synthétique qui sont des
déclarations très intéressantes
et instructives sur une ouverture
d'esprit nouvelle le pacte quels sont
dans votre esprit les priorités que vous
attendez dans les engagements des
enseignants qui concluraient ce pacte
individuel certes mais qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une volonté
ministérielle est-ce les devoirs faits
dans l'établissement sont les vacances
apprenantes quels sont les priorités
l'échange entre enseignants sur le suivi
individuel des élèves pour assurer leur
réussite
je rappelle que le problème l'objectif
de l'éducation c'est la réussite des
élèves et la transmission évidemment
d'un savoir
peut-être une dernière question mais
vous y avez répondu donc ou plus
exactement vous avez fixé un calendrier
c'est l'enseignement inclusif il y a
cette rencontre attendons là est
important qu'il ait lieu pour que chacun
mesure sa part de responsabilité
au regard de ce problème digestif
pardonnez-moi j'ai je reviens en arrière
juste sur un point dans les annonces de
l'été il y a la responsabilité du chef
d'établissement alors les établissements
existent lorsqu'il s'agit de lycée ou de
collège ils ont d'ailleurs des chefs
proviseurs principaux en ce qui concerne
les écoles c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué vous le savez et je voulais
savoir vous avez été très prudent vous
avez dit oui il y a une ouverture
n'est pas question de la généraliser
peut-être pas question de la génériser
mais si on pouvait expérimenter plus
largement je crois que vous auriez des
candidats et je souhaiterais connaître
le fond de votre pensée sur ce sujet
voici donc les quatre questions que je
souhaitais vous poser certes la
commission des finances ne peut que se
réjouir qu'il est un peu plus d'argent
et qu'on réfléchisse à modifier les
choses mais les questions que je vous
pose ne sont pas sans effet sur
l'engagement de mes collègues qui sont
pas tous aussi mesurés que je le suis
devenu avec l'âge
ce ministre je vais vous laisser
répondre aux deux rapporteurs
je vous remercie messieurs les
rapporteurs et je vais donc répondre à
vos questions peut-être en les
regroupant par famille parce que il y a
des regroupements entre vos deux
interventions et en commençant par la
revalorisation des enseignants et je
j'appuie votre
propos monsieur le rapporteur à propos
donc de la de la perte d'attractivité du
métier d'enseignant sur sur laquelle
nous avons déjà parlé de laquelle nous
avons déjà parlé la presse s'en est fait
l'écho de façon extrêmement large c'est
dernier mois et je dois vous dire que
les efforts que nous faisons ne vont pas
à notre sens inversé
brutalement les choses d'une année sur
l'autre c'est un travail de longue
haleine qui va prendre plusieurs années
cette revalorisation elle ne répond pas
en effet à l'ensemble des facteurs qui
permettent d'expliquer le faiblement des
concours et le faible nombre de
candidats vous avez je suis en accord
complet avec vous sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs la question du faible
recrutement ou des difficultés de
recrutement d'enseignants se posent à
l'échelle de toute l'Europe sauf dans
deux pays y compris dans des pays
voisins du nôtre comme l'Allemagne ou le
Luxembourg ou les rémunérations sont
beaucoup plus élevées qu'en France par
conséquent la question des rémunérations
même si elle est importante ne dit pas
tout il y a d'autres facteurs des
facteurs qui sont des facteurs de
conditions de travail en effet des
facteurs qui sont liés aussi je dirais à
la manière dont les jeunes se projettent
aujourd'hui dans le métier le métier a
été con pour des carrières longues
jusqu'à la retraite aujourd'hui les
jeunes que nous interrogeons les
étudiants envisagent l'enseignement pour
une période plus brève une dizaine
d'années avant de pouvoir faire autre
chose donc ils veulent des portes de
sortie si je puis dire dans les
trajectoires de carrière il y a des
portes d'entrée aussi pour les personnes
qui entrent après une première
expérience professionnelle donc il y a
un gros travail à mener du point de vue
des carrières professionnelles et puis
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous dire déjà je
le mentionnerai au passage à quel point
aussi la la place symbolique des
enseignants dans la société française
doit être revalorisée les enseignants
n'ont jamais été bien payés si je devais
le résumer ainsi il n'y a pas eu un
temps où leur rémunération était élevés
elle était relativement plus élevée il y
a 30 ans qu'aujourd'hui mais les
historiens de l'éducation
insiste sur le fait que les
rémunérations par exemple dans
l'entre-deux-guerres étaient des
rémunérations modestes avec même des
difficultés de vie pour les enseignants
du premier degré mais des rémunérations
qui étaient compensées par je dirais une
place sociale symbolique politique aussi
qui était tout à fait importante et donc
moi je réfléchis aussi à cette place des
enseignants dans la société française il
y a un sentiment parfois de déclassement
qui va au-delà des simples questions
financières à propos d'inégalités selon
la discipline
monsieur le rapporteur je
remarque que les deux disciplines qui
ont été les plus en tension et à propos
desquels nous avons eu le plus de
difficultés
pour cette rentrée 2022 n'ont pas été
les disciplines qui sont les plus en
concurrence sur le marché du travail les
plus en tension sur sur le marché du
travail ces deux disciplines ont été les
lettres classiques et l'allemand vous
conviendrez que ce sont des disciplines
qui sont un peu à contre intuition par
rapport à ce qu'on pourrait imaginer du
côté des mathématiques de la physique de
la
physique-chimie et donc il me semble que
la question du marché du travail dans sa
globalité y compris du marché du travail
privé n'est pas la seule question dans
la dans les difficultés de recrutement
que nous pouvons
que nous pouvons avoir
la question des démissions elle se pose
en effet monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez eu raison de dire que c'est des
missions sont importantes dans les cinq
premières années de la de du métier on
est à 0,4 % pour les 5 premières années
contre une moyenne de 0,2 % pour
l'ensemble de la carrière ce qui rejoint
d'ailleurs des données que nous avons à
l'échelle internationale les premières
années sont toujours des années de
démission avec des chiffres beaucoup
plus élevés dans les pays européens
voisins c'est souvent entre 4 et 6% dans
les pays européens donc on est encore à
un niveau beaucoup plus bas mais là où
je vous rejoins c'est que il y a une
pente qui est une pente croissante donc
on est encore très bas mais la pente des
démissions d'une pente croissante raison
de plus pour y travailler de façon
évidente et c'est pour cela d'ailleurs
que les premières années y prix du point
de vue de la revalorisation mais pas
seulement sont des années essentielles
sur lesquels il faut se pencher les
contractuels en effet nous avons recours
au contractuel dans des proportions qui
restent modestes en dépit de des
articles de presse on est entre 1 et
demi pour cent dans le premier degré
entre 6 et demi et 8% dans le second
degré avec des variations je le
conseille selon les régions et donc la
question des contractuels elle n'est pas
pour elle doit être envisagée de deux
manières à la fois de par dans une
situation qui n'est pas une situation
optimale puisque le rendement des
concours n'a pas été bon cette année un
rendement à
83%, mais aussi en effet nous avons
besoin d'enseignants contractuels de
façon je dirais structurelle là c'est un
niveau trop élevé en particulier dans
certains départements mais nous avons
besoin d'enseignants
actuelle de manière à ajuster finement
la notre offre à la demande et à pouvoir
répondre à un certain nombre de
difficultés
temporaire
à propos des
du pack et des missions nouvelles que
nous entendons proposer aux enseignants
volontaires
c'est mission nouvelle sont donc
discutées avec les organisations
syndicales jusqu'au 15 novembre puis
nous reprenons après les élections
professionnelles début janvier pour
conclure vers la fin février je ne sais
pas si nous parviendrons à un accord il
y a un éventail assez large de missions
que nous discutons avec les
organisations syndicales mais si je
devais puisque vous m'y invitez insister
sur quelques points je mentionnerai
trois points importants d'abord la
question des des remplacements de courte
durée ensuite la question du suivi et de
l'orientation des élèves c'est un point
sur lequel nous pouvons et devons faire
mieux particulièrement dans le second
degré particulièrement au lycée et enfin
le troisième point c'est celui de la
formation continue la formation continue
vous posiez la question également c'est
un élément tout à fait essentiel et pour
le premier degré et pour le second degré
nous avons besoin de former de manière
continue nos enseignants ne serait-ce
que parce que comme vous le savez en
formation initiale il faut reconnaître
que la formation initiale en France et
réduite par rapport à la formation La
formation initiale dans d'autres pays
vous l'avez vous même noté monsieur le
rapporteur dans votre rapport on a une
formation très académique une formation
au métier très réduite par opposition à
des pays où la formation au métier est
plus et donc dans l'immédiat avec les
enseignants que nous avons nous devons
faire un effort de formation continue y
compris dans des disciplines comme les
mathématiques qui ne sont pas les
disciplines les plus familières aux
enseignants du premier degré les
enseignants du premier degré viennent
plutôt du monde disons littéraire au
sens large du terme et donc il y a un
effort particulièrement à faire du côté
des professeurs des écoles qui fait
partie du plan mathématique
en ce qui concerne le premier degré je
vais simplement
mentionner la question de l'enseignement
et de l'école inclusive
que vous avez également mentionné
monsieur le rapporteur pour à la fois
souligner la nécessité nous avons créé
des postes d'Ash mais j'ai eu l'occasion
de souligner à quel point cette cette
question était une question qui
nécessitait d'être remise à plat tant le
système se trouve embolisé à la fois du
côté des instituts médicaux-éducatifs il
n'y a plus assez de place en institut
médico-éducatif et donc les les élèves
sont versés dans le milieu ordinaire qui
se trouve les classes ULIS sont
elles aussi pleines et nous avons des
donc des difficultés structurelles sans
compter avec les notifications des MDPH
qui pleuvent si vous me permettez
l'expression et qui nous pose des
difficultés tout à fait réelles et donc
il faut sortir d'une simple logique de
création de postes d'aesh création
nécessaire
mais qui ne nous permet pas de rattraper
la marée si vous ne permettez
l'expression pour mettre les choses à
plat avec les MDPH et puis réfléchir à
la meilleure manière d'accueillir les
enfants en situation de handicap je
voudrais justementner la question des
inégalités territoriales monsieur le
rapporteur que vous mentionniez à partir
du coût de la vie et c'est en effet un
facteur je dirais de de
répulsif dans dans le métier que d'être
nommé dans le secondaire dans des
académies où le coût de la vie est élevé
notamment le coût du logement pour ceux
qui concerne les académies
franciliennes et qui se combine bien
entendu à un moment où la rémunération
est basse puisqu'on entre comme néo
titulaire dans le métier donc là on a
une crise qui est à la fois celle du
coût de la vie et qui se combine bien
sûr à
à à la rémunération la question du
logement est une question sur laquelle
nous nous penchons très sérieusement
puisque c'est évidemment le logement qui
constitue un coût un coût majeur il y a
des tentatives qui ont été faites du
côté de la réservation de logement dans
le parc locatif
public mais c'est très coûteux et ça n'a
pas eu un succès absolument
extraordinaire en particulier parce que
les logements se trouvaient dans des
quartiers qui n'étaient pas forcément
des quartiers attractifs pour les
néo-titulaires et donc nous avons une un
sujet qui est également vrai dans
certaines
dans certains départements d'outre-mer
qui est celui du coût du logement et de
la manière dont on peut y répondre c'est
une question que le ministère de la
Santé avec les personnels de santé que
le ministère de l'Intérieur
avec les personnels les forces de
l'ordre à également et donc j'en ai j'ai
échangé à ce sujet avec mes avec les
collègues concernés pour réfléchir à une
offre de logement qui puisse être en
quelque sorte mutualisé
j'ai pardon j'ai oublié la question du
fond d'innovation pédagogique
pardonnez-moi je reviens un tout petit
peu en arrière ce fond d'innovation
pédagogique est mise en oeuvre à partir
du mois de janvier 2023 et non pas à
partir de la rentrée 2023 puisque nous
esquons que des projets pédagogiques
issus des concertations seront prêts à
partir de
l'hiver 2023 et que le financement
puisse intervenir très rapidement comme
le président de la République si est
engagé et donc il y a un
des opérations administratives à faire
de manière à transférer les sommes
d'argent depuis France 2030 vers les
rectorats puisque le financement se fera
à partir des des rectorats et nous avons
une question je crois qu'elle a été je
ne sais plus par lequel d'entre vous
elle a été posée nous avons
effectivement la question pour les qui
se posent pour les établissements du
premier degré c'est vous monsieur gros
Perrin puisque ces établissements du
premier degré n'ont pas de personnalité
financière si j'ose dire et donc à dans
le cas de l'expérience marseillaise le
financement à transiter par des
établissements du second degré qui ont
été en quelque sorte les
donc ça c'est fait par un par un passage
par les établissements du second degré
ça n'est pas une situation
optimale je le reconnais très volontiers
mais nous devons travailler
là-dessus il y a quelques obstacles
juridiques que nous devons résoudre pour
les établissements du premier degré
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
regrouper les questions une première
série de questions enfin une deuxième
sur la question du coup par parler pour
chacun des groupes en commençant par Max
Brisson
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre
le budget de l'Éducation nationale est
plus importants budget de l'État le
temps accordé en sciences publiques sans
parler de l'horaire parfois n'est
peut-être pas proportionnelle
tout le temps
mais peut-être pas pour ceux d'elle à ce
qu'il représente dans les dépenses
publiques d'où l'importance de nos
échanges du temps que vous y passez et
nous en remercions et je vous remercier
notre collègue rapporteur j'ai un gros
Perrin pour sa grande vigilance c'est
remarque juste à viser sur le budget et
saluer la sagesse et la modération de
Gérard Longuet dont je risque mon corps
défendant de m'éloigner quelque peu dans
ma dans mon intervention
il ressort de ce premier budgeture
d'abord que le Président de la
République a juste titre a fait
d'éducation vous l'avez rappelé une
priorité et a tenu des propos
extrêmement forts et je pense que pour
être tous d'accord sur le fait qu'il
s'agit
d'une politique volontariste qui était
attendue en vous écoutant monsieur le
ministre
j'ai du mal
à lire le contenu de votre petit
politique au delà des mots clés au delà
des titres chapitres et au-delà des
éléments de langage
j'y vois des tentatives de réponse sur
deux entre en résonance avec de nombreux
problèmes sectoriels
c'est louables mais à force d'avoir trop
de cap je risque je pense qu'on va finir
par affoler la boussole et se perdre en
chemin je prends deux trois exemples
d'abord la rémunération des enseignants
on peut aller faire
satisfaire et saluer je le fais les 935
millions d'euros que vous avez obtenus
de Bercy pour revaloriser les salaires
c'est l'essentiel
mais
vous avez fixé quelques règles de
répartition on peut s'étonner que face à
cette somme importante il est si peu sur
la réforme du métier d'enseignant
notre commission a eu souvent l'occasion
d'appeler votre prêté ses sœurs sur une
réforme de fond sur une véritable
réforme de la gestion des ressources
humaines du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale pour rompre par exemple
avec ce qui est un véritable bizutage
institutionnel des déo titulaires
car au-delà de la rémunération il y a
des questions premium sur la formation
sur l'entrée dans le métier
sur le déroulement de la carrière
nous pensons qu'il serait temps de
travailler à des déroulements de
carrière plus souples plus dynamique par
exemple nous l'avons proposé par une
démarche de contractualisation pour les
titulaires en cours de carrière afin de
réduire la seule entrée par l'ancienneté
et donc de prendre en compte des
réalités de terrain dont vient
d'ailleurs de parler excellent le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
gerlongées
nous pensons que le ministère
d'éducation nationale a besoin d'une
réforme en profondeur de sa gestion des
ressources humaines qui doit rompre avec
une culture
verticale
centralisée très globale et qui laisse
peu de place à une gestion plus
individualisée et de l'encontre des
réalités donc ma question est simple
avez-vous prévu des moyens spécifiques
pour initier une réforme de la gestion
des ressources humaines du ministère
au-delà de la valorisation salariale
quel projet et au-delà du constat
portez-vous donc pour réformer en
profondeur le déroulé de carrière des
enseignants
vous n'avez pas évoqué non plus
la réforme du Master mètre qui est
certainement aussi une des causes de la
difficulté que l'on a rencontrées
lors des derniers concours quel bilan
faites-vous de cette réforme
envisagez-vous de la faire évoluer
je voudrais prendre un deuxième exemple
concernant l'école du futur dotée d'un
fond d'innovation pédagogique dont vous
avez déjà parlé de 150 millions en 2023
et qui peut être porté à 500 millions
d'ici 2027 alors je me réjouis nous nous
sommes nombreux à nous réjouir dans
cette émission de cette prise de
conscience portée par le président du
public du besoin de donner plus de nos
autonomie et de liberté aux
établissements et à leur professeur
mais encore je m'interroge sur
l'ambition
l'autonomie des établissements scolaires
que le président République appelle de
ses vœux nécessite Satan bien plus que
le financement de projet par un appel à
projet centralisé
cela exige une réforme systémique et
certainement un travail législatif on
vient d'un apport d la question
peut-il y avoir autonomie pour les
écoles primaires s'il n'y a pas
personnalité morale peut-il y avoir
autonomie pour les écoles primaires
c'est les directeurs ne pour n'ont pas
d'exercices de leur route d'une autorité
au delà d'autorité fonctionnelle
apportée par la réforme RIAC finalement
vous avez proposé une réponse qui
s'apparente drôlement ce qui a été
rejeté dans cette assemblée et qui était
sûrement public locaux des savoirs
fondamentaux rattachant les écoles
primaires au collège ne craignez-vous
pas de générer la même colère tout à la
fois des mers ruraux qui verront des
risques de disparition de leurs écoles
et des syndicats d'enseignants en tout
cas est assez surprenant de voir que la
solution que vous apportez est
exactement celle qui a été rejetée par
tous les bancs de l'Assemblée voilà deux
ans ici même
je puisque vous avez évoqué des sujets
qui sont tout à fait en lien avec le
budget je dirais je poserai je
terminerai là-dessus de 3 questions vous
avez lancé quelques titres de chapitre
sur le collège et la voie
professionnelle nous attendons du
contenu nous serons patients sachez que
nous avons envisagé que le groupe les
républicains a souhaité un débat sur la
réforme de l'enseignement professionnel
qui aura lieu dans l'hémicycle le 14
novembre et puis la dernière fois vous
aviez souhaité que je vous pose des
questions sur l'instrument des langues
régionales je ne l'avais pas fait donc
grand et le plaisir que j'ai de vous
donner satisfaction donc je voudrais
savoir quel est votre position sur
l'enseignement des langues régionales
par la méthode de l'immersion dans les
écoles publiques
votre avis sur la question du passage
des épreuves du brevet du baccalauréat
longue régionale une réponse est
attendue pour des enseignants qui vont
bientôt avoir achever le programme du
premier trimestre et puis où en
sommes-nous du rapport des députés et
kerlocks qui est préconisé une loi cadre
sur les langues régionales mais j'ai cru
comprendre que vous n'aviez guère envie
de présenter des lois devant le
Parlement je ne sais d'ailleurs pas
pourquoi mais pourtant je pense que ça
au sujet sur l'autonomie de servissement
ou sur le ou la place des langues
régionales dans d'autres saignement ne
vous permettra pas d'éviter de passer
devant le Parlement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors tout
d'abord vous nous avez parlé d'une
augmentation du budget de 6% mais nous
vivons un contexte où l'inflation pour
le moment est estimé provisoirement à
6%, et pourraient être revu à la baisse
donc cela à la hausse pardon cela
interpelle un petit peu je voudrais
reprendre vos propos vous avez dit qu'il
était temps de reconnaître un engagement
sans faille de la part des enseignants
leur dévouement trop longtemps peut
rétribuer alors juste valeur et que cela
nécessitait un sursaut mais par ailleurs
vous nous parlez de pacte enseignant ou
là vous voulez en fait les faire
travailler plus pour gagner plus alors
moi je comprends en fait que vous
sous-entendez que les professeurs ne
seraient pas actuellement déjà au
maximum de leurs capacité de travail et
cela m'interpelle vous allez beaucoup
parler du pacte d'enseigne des
enseignants et que vous étiez en
négociation vous avez parlé de quelques
pistes notamment par exemple une
indemnité de suivi d'orientation mais
qui existe déjà pour le second degré
je voudrais revenir sur les suppressions
de postes donc vous avez annoncé mille
postes d'enseignants supprimés dans le
1er degré comment espérer dans ces
conditions mettre en oeuvre même si à
moins d'élèves mais mettre en œuvre de
façon satisfaisante la poursuite des
politiques de dédoublement en repérer
plus et du plafonnement du nombre
d'élèves par classe parce que cela
demande beaucoup de moyens
et on manquait aussi par ailleurs pas
mal de remplaçant dans le premier degré
avez-vous à ce sujet des éléments
chiffrés à nous communiquer sur le
dédoublement actuel des classes de
grandes sections maternelle Vous
confirmez nous que le taux est de 100%
pour le dédoublement des classes de CPCE
1 en repérer plus ainsi que pour le
plafonnement des classes de grande
section en CP et CE1 or éducation
prioritaire
et puis je regarde à regret je constate
que de nouvelles suppressions d'emplois
dans le second degré sont là
-480 postes c'est quand même moins
17500 emplois entre 2018 2021 a rebours
pour le second degré de l'évolution des
effectifs
il y aura certainement recours aux
heures supplémentaires
pour compenser ces suppressions de poste
est-ce que vous avez j'ai pas trouvé
dans le bleu des éléments sur la
consommation des heures supplémentaires
parce que je sais que c'est très
difficile pour les enseignants d'en
accepter plus que les deux heures
statutaires qu'ils ont
le recours au contrat actuel vous avez
annoncé le lancement de concours
exceptionnel à destination des du
premier degré dans trois académies
Créteil de Versailles et la Guyane quid
des académies qui ne sont pas concernés
par cette démarche ainsi que des
contractuels exerçants dans le second
degré on a beaucoup parlé des colles
inclusives et malgré des recrutements
hausse le Nord d'accompagnants en
situation d'handicap reste insuffisant
je crois qu'elle est 44% des personnels
de direction qui signalaient qu'au moins
un aesh manquait à la rentrée pour
accompagner les élèves on a même bu
apparaître pour compenser les
insuffisances de l'État on recourt à des
aesh privés notamment via des structures
associatives qui rentraient dans les
écoles ces ESH c'est quand même un
mécanisme un peu pervers qui crée une
rupture d'égalité entre les parents qui
peuvent se permettre à un recours un
recours à une telle solution et les
autres
et puis il attire également des avsh qui
éprouvent des conditions d'exercices
peut-être plus favorables quelle est la
position du ministère sur le sujet
disposez-vous d'éléments chiffrés sur
l'évolution du phénomène et surtout de
la revalorisation de 10% annoncé et des
4000 nouveaux recrutements prévus cette
rentrée que prévoyez-vous de faire pour
apporter des réponses à la hauteur des
carences actuelles de l'école inclusive
et puis je souhaite vous alerter sur un
point plus précis celui de la formation
des aesh qui est considéré comme
aujourd'hui comme insuffisante par les
principaux concernés et dans le PLF on
constate une baisse de l'enveloppe
destinée à la formation des aesh alors
même que leur nombre doit augmenter de
4000 cette année comment expliquer vous
ce paradoxe
et puis revalorisation exceptionnelle
alors vous avez dit 2000 euros net pour
ceux qui débutent dans la fonction
est-ce que c'est net est-ce que c'est
primes incluses ce que vous savez quand
on est enseignant une prime c'est pas
une augmentation du point d'indice ça
n'a rien à voir
c'est pas la même chose du tout et
j'attire vraiment votre attention sur le
fait que vous le ciblez beaucoup sur le
début de carrière et que ça risque de
décourager aussi certains parce que vous
parlez d'un accès à leur classe mais ça
ça vient très tard dans la carrière des
enseignants et je me demande aussi la
marge de manœuvre que vous avez au
regard de l'évolution des crédits
programmés pour la mission dans les
prochaines années est-ce que les
montants prévus permettront vraiment
d'avoir une montée en puissance de cette
revalorisation
voilà j'ai déjà beaucoup parlé je vous
remercie merci Annick billon
pardon merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour déjà ces
réponses aux nombreuses questions posées
par nos rapporteurs et je vais essayer
de raccourcir mon intervention dans la
mesure où de nombreux sujets ont été
évoqués avec notamment l'école du futur
l'attractivité du métier d'enseignant et
les trajectoires de carrière
permettez-moi de revenir juste sur les
aesh qui viennent d'être évoqués par
notre collègue Marie-Pierre Monnier en
réalité beaucoup travaillent encore à
temps partiel malgré l'instauration des
pials et en fait de nombreuses académies
restent encore en tension nous avons eu
l'occasion de d'auditionner la rectrice
de Versailles que nous avons entendu en
audition et qui nous faisait part d'un
manque de 700 aesh aesh pardon rien que
pour sa seule académie donc bien entendu
l'attractivité de du métier d'avesh
reste encore assez difficile on va dire
à la fois pour cause de salaire mais
également pour l'organisation du temps
nous préconisions dans notre rapport
bilan des mesures éducatives avec
Marie-pierre Monnier et Max Brisson de
mettre un focus sur la formation donc je
voudrais vous interroger un sur ces
cette formation qui doit être étoffée et
également sur les ESH Marie-Pierre
Monnier vient de le demander un message
privé qui sont semble-t-il autorisés
dans les établissements publics qu'ils
soient collèges ou lycée en fonction de
la vie du directeur du chef
d'établissement donc voilà comment
comment s'organise cela une deuxième
question qui n'a pas été posée jusqu'à
jusqu'à lors sur l'éducation à la
sexualité vous vous êtes exprimé depuis
et à la vie affective depuis la rentrée
la loi vous le savez prévoir des heures
par an et par niveau obligatoire
évidemment cette loi n'est pas appliquée
avec la délégation aux droits des femmes
nous avons rendu un rapport sur Porno
l'enfer du le décor et les ravages
finalement du biberonnage de toutes une
génération à la pornographie et non pas
au cours d'éducation à la sexualité on
le sait c'est en réalité c'est c'est ces
élèves qui ont été interrogés disposent
en moyenne de 3 séances sur les 21 qui
sont obligatoires dans la loi donc nous
démontrons au cours de dans ce rapport
que ni le volume ni la qualité ne sont
au rendez-vous donc il est bien entendu
question d'appliquer la loi mais aussi
d'adapter les contenus parce que si on
met dans on met dans les les programmes
désormais de l'éducation à la sexualité
de l'éducation à l'anatomie par exemple
tout en sachant qu'un enfant sur trois
de moins de 15 ans non un enfant sur
trois de moins de 12 ans est exposé à de
la pornographie depuis l'âge de 8 ans et
2 sur 3 moins de 15 ans on sera un petit
peu hors sujet donc il faut à qui est le
volume mais qui est les contenus
également je voudrais aussi revenir sur
la médecine scolaire et d'ailleurs sa
corrobore parce que dans nos travaux
nous avons démontré à la fois qu'il y
avait besoin d'éducation à la sexualité
mais il y avait aussi besoin d'espaces
d'écoute donc nous avons aujourd'hui si
mes chiffres sont bons un médecin pour
12572 élèves et un infirmier pour 1300
élèves donc les besoins sont criants et
à côté de ça il y a aussi un déficit de
pied pédiatrie donc la médecine scolaire
a d'autant plus sa place aujourd'hui
puisque nous sommes aussi déficitaires
en pédiatrie de ville et pour
l'accompagnement des enfants donc quand
sera-t-il pour cette année scolaire en
termes de médecine scolaire je vais pas
parler de la pénurie des enseignants
tout ça a été déjà évoqué nous avions
dans notre rapport bilan des mesures
éducatif proposé qu'il un module dédié
dans les innp à la maternelle donc quid
de ce module et je voudrais peut-être
revenir aussi sur pour finir sur deux
sujets la filière mathématique avec leur
darkos nous avions auditionné le
collectif mate science vous avez fait
des annonces les annonces sur pour
essayer d'inverser la tendance
aujourd'hui de nombreuses jeunes filles
ne sont plus en capacité de s'orienter
vers les filières scientifiques c'est
d'autant plus criant que ça fait
maintenant quasiment deux ans donc il y
a urgence comment allons-nous réussir à
inverser la tendance et puis un dernier
sujet si vous le permettez l'accès au
grade élevé selon le panorama
statistique des personnels de
l'enseignement scolaire 2021-2022 on
note un déséquilibre au profit des
hommes dans l'accès au grade les plus
élevés hors classe et classe
exceptionnelle dans le premier degré 18%
des professeur des écoles sont en
hors-classe 16% pour les femmes 11% sont
en classe exceptionnelle 5% pour les
femmes dans le second degré 7% des
enseignantes sont en classe
exceptionnelles contre 9% des
enseignants ce déséquilibre ne peut
s'expliquer semble-t-il que par des
différences démographiques il semblent
en réalité que les hommes passent plus
rapidement que les femmes à la
hors-classe et à la classe
exceptionnelle même dans le premier
degré ou pourtant ils sont depuis
longtemps moins nombreux que les femmes
on entend conséquence un creusement des
différences d'indices entre les hommes
et les femmes à partir de 20 ans
d'ancienneté et donc des inégalités de
salaire non négligeables en fin de
carrière donc quand n'est-il et que
proposez-vous même si ma voisine dit
c'est partout pareil
Céline Brulin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez parlé d'un budget de
rupture ça n'est pas le cas en ce qui
concerne les suppressions de postes qui
se poursuivent et je crois que vous ne
pouvez pas compter uniquement sur les
effets démographiques pour améliorer le
taux d'encadrement puisque
on a par exemple encore des départements
le mien est concerné ou horrep nous
n'atteignons pas les 24 élèves par
classe où il y a des classes à bien plus
de 24 élèves et où quelqu'un d'autre l'a
évoqué avant moi toutes les grandes
sections en repérer plus ne sont pas
encore dédoublés et donc je crois que
cet élément et cet exemple suffit à
montrer que c'est une mauvaise idée de
supprimer des postes c'est encore plus
vrai dans le secondaire où là les
effectifs continuent de croître pour
encore quelques années me semble-t-il
sur les
revalorisations
salariales je rejoins ce qu'a dit
Jacques gros Perrin il a dû le dire
beaucoup mieux que moi mais en substance
que les forces financiers ne suffira pas
à inverser la tendance à la crise de
recrutement qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est aussi notre avis
et je voudrais vous interroger plus
précisément sur la part que vous appelez
pacte dans la revalorisation des
enseignants puisque vous dites et alors
là je vous rejoins complètement que on a
besoin de redonner aux enseignants une
place la place sociale qu'il mérite dans
notre société mais je ne crois pas que
c'est en disant que pour gagner plus il
va falloir qu'ils exercent de nouvelles
missions que nous allons contribuer à
redonner la place sociale qu'ils doivent
avoir dans notre pays l'autre élément
c'est que dans le secondaire
cette optique a déjà été expérimentée
via l'augmentation des heures
supplémentaires et que je ne sais pas ce
qu'il en est cette année mais je sais
que Jacques gros Perrin que je cite une
deuxième fois
avait montré dans un précédent rapport
budgétaire qu'il y avait 12 millions
d'euros de crédit non consommés à
travers ses heures supplémentaires parce
que les enseignants ne pouvez pas les
faire et effectivement les enseignants
travaillent en moyenne quarantaine
d'heures dans notre pays et donc il est
évidemment difficile qu'ils en fassent
plus sur
l'axe que vous avez appelé l'acte 2 de
l'école inclusive je j'espère me tromper
en ayant compris dans vos propos
qu'il allait falloir compenser la
faiblesse
qui demeure des rémunérations des aesh
par les 35 heures parce que et ça a été
montré par des rapports de nos collègues
souvent c'est ce sont les besoins de
l'institution scolaire qui priment sur
le besoin des enfants à accompagner et
que je pense que si on veut vraiment
faire un acte 2 de l'école inclusive
alors il faut que ce soit
prioritairement les besoins des enfants
vous avez évoqué là je vous rejoins
aussi le fait que ça n'était pas l'école
et l'éducation nationale qui pouvait
accueillir tous les enfants en situation
de handicap qu'il manquait de place dans
les institutions spécialisées c'est vrai
mais alors quel dialogue se développe
avec le ministère de la Santé avec les
départements qui sont quand même ceux
qui doivent enfin qui créent ces places
et je pense que enfin il faut il faut
qu'il y ait une réflexion d'ensemble me
semble-t-il de ce point de vue là sur
l'école du futur je voudrais insister
lorsqu'on dit des collègues c'est à dire
le manque de base juridique aujourd'hui
pour ne serait-ce que
affecter les crédits que vous identifiez
pour des écoles qui s'engageraient dans
un projet pédagogique innovant mais
au-delà des risques juridiques moi je
voudrais savoir parce que vous avez dit
que ces projets innovants devaient viser
l'amélioration de la réussite des élèves
je ne crois pas connaître un seul
établissement scolaire de ce pays qui ne
travaille pas à l'amélioration de la
réussite des élèves après tout le monde
ne part pas du moins même point de
départ et ça peut être un critère pour
attribuer des moyens supplémentaires
mais j'aimerais savoir comment les
rectorats puisque ce sont eux
visiblement qui vont devoir affecter et
départager les établissements scolaires
qui voudront bénéficier de ces crédits
sur quels critères
pédagogique et sociaux est-ce qu'ils
vont pouvoir se baser et enfin la santé
des jeunes un certain nombre de choses
ont été dites à l'instant sur la
médecine scolaire
plusieurs rapports montrent
l'ampleur des méfaits de la crise
sanitaire sur la santé et sur la santé
mentale notamment de nos enfants et de
nos jeunes je ne considère pas là non
plus que c'est à l'éducation nationale
de répondre en totalité à cet enjeu mais
je ne pense qu'elle ne peut pas ne pas y
prendre sa part or dans ce budget il n'y
a absolument rien
et aucune amélioration en termes de
santé de médecine scolaire qui est
pourtant sinistrée
et puis apporter alors moi je
compléterai simplement parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dit et
demandés sur les aesh en rappelant quand
même que le budget enfin a été quand
même augmenté de 80 millions et même si
ça reste que
substantiel comme augmentation on peut
quand même
la saluer et ma question sur les aesh
étaient avant de vous imposer une autre
sur l'enseignement français à l'étranger
était sur le fait que lors de vos
engagements pris pour améliorer leurs
conditions
que pouvons-nous avoir comme piste je
dirais voilà concrète pour peut-être
rendre ce métier plus attractif et
améliorer les conditions de travail ça
c'est pour les aesh au plan national
puisqu'à l'international et bien le
recrutement sort de votre champ de
compétences puisque à l'étranger les
familles doivent recruter elles-mêmes
leurs absh dans le cadre du réseau
homologué français à l'étranger donc ce
qui m'amène à mes deux questions
suivantes tout à l'heure on évoquait les
masters meufs par l'une des questions
posées moi j'aimerais vous alerter sur
un sujet particulièrement
celui des masters meufs avec module
enseignement français à l'étranger où on
prépare nos enseignants à venir
rejoindre cette expérience de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger et
bien aujourd'hui j'ai enfin je rentre
d'un long déplacement où j'ai pu à
l'étranger où j'ai pu rencontrer un
certain nombre d'acteurs dont ceux qui
forment aujourd'hui à ce module et il me
disent avec une certaine préoccupation
ces inspects en particulier que ceux qui
viennent capter nos
enseignants nos futurs enseignants et
bien sont aussi désormais d'autres pays
et il n'entre pas dans le modèle
français à l'étranger alors que nous les
formons j'en veux pour preuve le Canada
le Luxembourg pour ne nommer que alors
pour diverses raisons alors souvent la
greffe ne prend pas aussi parce qu'il y
a un peu le miroir aux alouettes on
pense que mieux payés c'est mieux mais
mieux payé souvent c'est plus beaucoup
plus même de de temps aussi mais
néanmoins nous perdons un certain nombre
de ses étudiants enfin enseignants qui
sortent de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger alors que nous souhaitons
nous aussi puisque nous avons un réseau
homologué je vous rappelle de près de
560 établissements à l'étranger et il
nous faut aussi des enseignants
compétents et donc former en amont de la
prise de fonction j'aimerais également
parce que c'est un deuxième sujet
d'alerte sur lequel je suis sensibilisée
sans arrêt par des enseignants
si j'ai salué en montant et je continue
à saluer ce café
monsieur Jeffrey en sa qualité de RH au
ministère en demandant en 2019 par le
biais d'un décret à nos professeurs
français de l'étrangers détachés de
l'éducation nationale après deux
missions de trois années de revenir en
France et de ne pas y faire toutes leurs
carrière ou y revenir un temps et
repartir ensuite et je trouve ça tout à
fait pertinent nécessaire pour avoir été
un ancien chef d'établissement je pense
qu'il est bon qu'on se confronte lequel
la réalité française et pas que à celle
du modèle français à l'étranger
puisqu'on est des fonctionnaires
d'éducation nationale mais aujourd'hui
j'ai un problème et un problème
d'importance à régler avec ces
personnels et qui devient aussi votre
problème c'est leur retour puisque c'est
vrai quand on est Français de l'étranger
on est toujours alors dans une catégorie
à part comme si nous étions des
lentilles comme si nous partions tous au
soleil gagner beaucoup plus d'argent
qu'ailleurs je fais tomber tout de suite
les tabous moi je vis en Espagne à
majeur que les professeurs sont payés
1400 euros par mois voilà ça c'est la
réalité qu'il faut connaître oui il fait
bon certes mais pas moins pas plus que
dans le sud de la France donc ceci étant
dit je tenais à dire que lorsqu'on va
leur demander de rentrer à ses
professeurs ou passer le concours parce
que certains sont français
au sens qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
tous natifs d'une langue s'ils sont
professeur de langue et bien ma question
est que faisons-nous aujourd'hui pour
eux parce que moi mon problème c'est que
il quand il reviennent ces enseignants
moi ils me disent mais on ne met pas en
avant nos compétences souvent ils
parlent une langue de langue même trois
langues et on ne peut pas les
reconnaître dans ce qu'on appelle une
DNL de l'étranger ils sont obligés de
revenir comme tout à chacun et on
n'arrive pas à leur donner des postes à
profil qui correspondent aux compétences
qu'ils ont acquises à l'étranger et ça
c'est un sujet j'ai rencontré souvent et
encore récemment vos services au
ministère mais j'aimerais vraiment
monsieur le ministre avoir un engagement
de votre part pour que nous les
considérions au retour voilà parce que
sinon si nous ne faisons pas ils vont
démissionner de l'éducation nationale et
il resteront à l'étranger
Monique de Marco
j'ai compléter donc les questions qui
ont déjà été posées je reprends celles
sur la médecine scolaire au cours des
dernières années les missions d'évoluent
aux infirmiers médecins se sont
diversifiés notamment à renforcement de
la lutte contre des violences subies par
l'enfant y compris intrafamilial mais il
y a également de dépistage des
harcèlement scolaires donc un élève sur
10 serait concerné
pourtant dans le même temps en disant le
nombre des médecins scolaires est passé
de 1261 11 temps complet à 843 et suivi
personnel infirmier de
8533 à
700 7579 comment comptez-vous renforcer
le rôle primordial de la médecine
scolaire c'est ma première question j'ai
également une question concernant les
raz des difficultés nous sont remontées
en local d'établissement qui ne dispose
plus de psychologues au sein de leur A à
Z le réseau d'aide spécialisée pour les
enfants en difficulté pour la deuxième
année consécutive c'est le problème
s'accroît pouvez-vous nous faire un état
des lieux à ce sujet et plus largement
de l'état des Raz et de l'évolution des
moyens humains qui leur sont consacrés
dans le cas de ce projet de loi de
finances
et dernière remarque j'attends avec
impatience
donc votre réponse concernant donc le
rôle des langues régionales et en
particulier l'enseignement Paris
immersion je vous remercie
d'avoir fait
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez la chance d'avoir un
ministre qui
embrasse suffisamment de matière pour
laisser des questions à chaque membre
des groupes voilà moi je pratique un
sport d'endurance depuis quelques années
qui est celui du harcèlement des
ministres au sujet de l'activité
physique
quotidienne aussi bien mise de la santé
ministre des Sports qui pensent que tout
va bien et moi je suis un peu moins
optimiste sur
la mise en place de cette APQ depuis la
rentrée scolaire je voulais savoir si
vous avez déjà une évaluation comment
vous comptez l'affaire vous nous parlez
de la de votre souhait de la réussite
des élèves c'est quand même les études
ont prouvé que c'en était un facteur
important et qui demande pas beaucoup de
moyens financiers mais une véritable
volonté politique
deuxième point nous avons fait à la
demande de la Commission une mission
d'information sur la délinquance des
mineurs avec Céline Boulais peronnier et
des collègues de la commission des lois
et le premier critère qui était le
premier opéra c'est celui du décrochage
scolaire je voudrais savoir où on en est
sur le décrochage scolaire avec des
choses un petit peu US qu'on voit que
pour qu'un l'éducation nationale
reconnaisse qu'un enfant attend
décrochage scolaire il faut que les
parents l'enfant soient venus signer la
reconnaissance du décrochage il y a des
choses qui sont un peu particulières
c'est comme l'exclusion
temporaire d'élèves dont on veut au
contraire raccrocher l'intérêt
à l'enseignement scolaire donc
j'aimerais avoir un peu vos avis je
voudrais aussi vous vous alerter au
sujet de d'un sujet particulier et avec
plus d'acuité depuis la crise
énergétique il y a vous savez comment
fonctionne le financement des écoles
privées par les par les communes qui
doivent financer au nombre d'élèves en
fonction du coût
de fonctionnement de chaque élève dans
leurs écoles là on a quelques exemples
de communes ou l'école privée étant
attractive
attire des élèves qui vident les classes
de
l'école publique rendant par moyenne il
suffit d'avoir fait un peu de division à
l'école pour savoir que le coût du coup
fonctionnement par élève va augmenter et
beaucoup avec les coûts de l'énergie
qu'on chauffe une classe pour même à 19
degrés pour 25 ou pour 20 élèves c'est
c'est le même coup et le pourcentage est
plus important et donc doivent payer
davantage puisqu'il y a plus d'élèves
qui partent et parfois on va jusqu'à des
fermetures de classe par manque d'élèves
donc des conditions d'accueil qui sont
moins favorables et c'est un véritable
cercle vicieux moi je pense qu'il faut
absolument se pencher sur
la façon dont les les communes doivent
financer les élèves en dans les écoles
privées parce que on est dans une dans
une pyrale qui me paraît inquiétante
parlant de privé je voudrais aussi vous
alerter sur
le recrutement des grandes écoles de
commerce on voit que les écoles de
commerce quand on regarde le le
classement des prépas et bien pour
l'école de commerce il y a que trois
écoles de
prépa qui soit public sur 10
pour le recrutement des élèves dans les
grandes écoles de commerce moi je pense
qu'il faut quand même veiller à ce qui
est pas un déclassement de l'école
publique et surtout sur les prépas les
classes prépa aux grandes écoles
dans le même domaine il y a avec notre
collègue on a assisté au World Game les
jeux vidéo qui est un domaine
d'excellence en France qui propose aussi
des emplois et pour lesquels il y a
aucune formation
publique en France il y a que des
formations privées on l'éducation
nationale l'orientation a complètement
délaissé ce secteur et puis donc je
serais pas sur le problème de la
médecine scolaire mais savoir où en sont
les discussions et les réflexions sur
les mutualisations avec compte tenu de
la démographie
des personnels médicaux des
mutualisations avec les PMI et les
services médico-sociaux des départements
pour pouvoir justement mutualiser les
moyens et pas avoir des fêtes redondance
ou parallèles
à cette série de questions il y a
d'autres collègues qui se sont inscrits
mais qui viendront par la suite
évidemment certains thèmes se coup
ent merci monsieur le Président voilà
une belle brassée de questions
auxquelles je vais m'efforcer de
répondre en regroupant peut-être des
questions lorsqu'elles se recoupent les
unes les autres et en commençant par les
questions du sénateur Brisson je vais
simplement poser quelques éléments
globaux en insistant sur trois points
qui sont trois points essentiels pour
moi d'abord celui de la hausse du niveau
scolaire des élèves vous savez que les
classements internationaux en
particulier
ne placent pas la France en position si
favorable je vais le dire comme cela
dans un certain nombre de disciplines
comme les mathématiques mais ça n'est
pas la seule discipline concernée donc
nous avons une question d'abord de
niveau scolaire général et nous sommes
même alerté par des des évaluations à
l'entrée en seconde ou bien en troisième
pour les langues vivantes évaluation
aussi ou test de positionnement après le
collège donc nous avons d'abord un sujet
qui est celui du niveau général il y a
un travail qui a été fait ces dernières
années du côté de l'école primaire il
faut laisser le temps à ce travail de ce
de ce matérialiser et de donner ses
effets plan mathématiques le plan
français l'accent mis sur les savoirs
fondamentaux à l'école primaire il y a
eu la réforme du lycée qui a été impacté
par la crise sanitaire d'ailleurs donc
son évaluation n'est pas encore complète
j'ai prolongé de ce point de vue là le
comité de suivi de la réforme du lycée
présidé par Pierre Mathiot qui travaille
et qui va
proposer qui propose déjà des retouches
et des améliorations à une réforme du
lycée qui n'est pas parfaite mais qui
est perfectible et puis nous avons entre
les deux si je puis dire le collège et
là on voit c'est un sujet de
préoccupation majeure pour nous là je
parle toujours de cette catégorie du
niveau scolaire général puisque à
l'entrée au collège à peu près 20% donc
en 6e des élèves sont en difficulté
scolaire voire en grande difficulté
scolaire comme les tests les évaluations
qui ont lieu au mois de septembre nous
allons publier bientôt les résultats en
français et en mathématiques le montre
donc on a un gros travail de ce côté là
et puis c'est le lieu de ce que
j'appelle aussi la grande divergence
c'est-à-dire les trajectoires scolaires
qui vont diverger entre celles et ceux
qui vont mener des trajectoires ils ont
normal et puis celles et ceux qui vont
qui vont plonger jusqu'à faire de telle
sorte que un quart des élèves du collège
soit en difficulté avec les difficultés
qui s'ensuivent y compris pour le lycée
donc on a un gros sujet qui est le sujet
de l'élévation du niveau général de nos
élèves
avec un focus particulier sur la
situation du collège et à partir de la
semaine prochaine nous allons commencer
à faire des propositions
importantes en ce sens en commençant par
la classe de 6e le deuxième chapitre
essentiel structurant c'est celui des
inégalités scolaires
et parmi les inégalités scolaires il y a
les inégalités filles garçons il y a les
inégalités sociales qui sont très
accentuées en France l'école française a
du mal à effacer ou à compenser les
inégalités de naissance d'autres types
d'inégalités liées à l'école inclusive
dont vous avez beaucoup parler si je
m'arrête un instant sur la question des
inégalités sociales ces inégalités
apparaissent d'ailleurs de façon très
crue avec la publication il y a beaucoup
d'articles de presse ces temps-ci dans
la presse régionale dans le monde cet
après-midi lié à la mise à disposition
en Open Data des
IPS des indices de positionnement
sociaux des établissements collèges et
lycée qui
indique les écarts très importants de
positionnement sociaux entre les
établissements et invite bien entendu à
agir parce qu'on sait que là aussi en
comparaison internationale la France et
n'est pas bien placé quant à la
réduction des inégalités de naissance
par le système scolaire qui tend plutôt
à les reproduire pour nous dire très
rapidement donc nous allons aussi de ce
côté là faire une série de proposition à
partir de la semaine prochaine allant
dans le sens de la mixité scolaire
allant dans le sens d'un meilleur
équilibre entre les établissements
favorisés et les établissements moins
favorisés du point de vue de l'égalité
fille garçon je vais y revenir par le
biais des sciences puisque madame la
sénatrice vous m'y avait invité et je
sais à quel point
madame la sénatrice darkos vous êtes
mobilisé sur cette question donc j'y
reviendrai spécifiquement mais on a un
gros sujet qui est celui des inégalités
puis enfin on a un dernier sujet qui est
la question que nous regroupons sous le
chapitre du bien-être alors vous pourrez
considérer que le bien-être ça a pas
beaucoup d'importance mais en fait
toutes les études montrent que le
bien-être que le bonheur à être à
l'école disons-le comme cela est un
élément tout à fait décisif dans le la
réussite scolaire dans la trajectoire
scolaire dans le plaisir de travailler
dans le plaisir de faire des efforts ça
inclut aussi la question du climat
scolaire c'est une variable qui est
mesurée aussi à l'échelle internationale
que celle du climat scolaire et on peut
y inclure des questions comme celle de
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
on est dans la semaine avec la Journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire dans
toujours et avec la généralisation du
programme phare pour les écoles
primaires et pour les collèges je
pourrais vous en entretenir si vous le
souhaitez mais également tout un
ensemble de rubriques tout à fait
importantes comme en particulier
l'éducation à la sexualité sur laquelle
je reviendrai bientôt donc
ose du niveau scolaire ça c'est
indispensable on ne peut pas se
satisfaire du positionnement général et
du glissement de d'une partie importante
de la population scolaire du point de
vue des résultats scolaires
lutte contre les inégalités scolaires ça
c'est aussi très important comme je l'ai
indiqué et enfin bien-être des élèves
qui nécessitent aussi
une mobilisation et des éléments sur
lesquels nous allons faire des
propositions dans les semaines à venir
et je serai heureux là aussi de
développer ses propositions si cela bien
entendu vous agréez voilà globalement
l'architecture ensuite je viens à des
questions un peu plus précises à
commencer monsieur le sénateur Brisson
par la question des DRH et je sais que
vous avez travaillé en 2018 sur un
rapport sur le métier d'enseignant que
que un rapport tout à fait intéressant
qui
[Musique]
va dans dans notre sens à plusieurs
égards la gestion des RH elle fait
l'objet depuis quelques années d'une
d'une d'un changement peut-être très peu
visible de l'extérieur qui est ce qu'on
appelle la RH de proximité il y a un
très grand développement de la gestion
rh de proximité à l'échelle des
établissements qui donnent des résultats
tout à fait intéressants du point de vue
des conseils de carrière de mutation
éventuellement de changement de carrière
et cette RH de proximité elle contribue
à rompre avec la verticalité et la
centralité que vous soulignez
précédemment il y a enfin tout un
ensemble de questions derrière les RH
que j'ai évoqué en parlant des
déroulements de carrière qui en effet
doivent être revus à l'aune des
aspirations nouvelles des enseignants la
question des mutations est une question
importante dans le second degré en effet
puisqu'on a une disjonction entre les
souhaits de mutation
et bien entendu nos besoins qui sont des
besoins qui ne sont pas ajustés aux
souhaits des enseignants donc nos
besoins importants en particulier dans
les académies franciliennes là où
beaucoup de néo-titulaires sont nommés
et on a une question extrêmement
complexe qui est qui consiste à essayer
de mieux ajuster les demandes de
mutation à now à nos besoins globaux et
là des collègues ultramarins par exemple
les collègues ultramarins sont très
sensibles à cette question des mutations
qui peut se jouer sur plusieurs milliers
de kilomètres nous essayons d'y
travailler la question qui est
extrêmement complexe mais je vais dans
votre sens si j'ai bien compris votre
propos à propos donc d'une démarche de
contractualisation il me semble que
quand on est nommé très loin de chez soi
pour le dire rapidement il est
raisonnable d'avoir une perspective sur
X années de mutation de retour chez soi
en tout cas de mutation vers une autre
académie pour l'instant c'est encore
extrêmement flou pour des enseignants
qui ont parfois l'impression d'être
coincée dans une académie ou dans un
département qui ne correspond pas à leur
choix de vie et à leur volonté de
rentrer par exemple dans leur région
d'origine donc il y a cette question de
la disons du de perspective de
calendrier qui me semble en effet
pouvoir être posé
à propos de
la de la voie professionnelle des
échanges sont en cours dans le cadre de
groupe de travail qui ont été mises en
place par la ministre délégué Carole
Grandjean qui s'occupe de ce dossier et
cette
réforme donc de la voie professionnelle
et des lycées professionnels on est
assez premiers éléments je pourrais
revenir en détail enfin en tout cas sur
les grandes lignes du diagnostic à
propos de des lycées professionnels mais
je veux signaler à ce stade la démarche
qui est celle de de groupe de travail
visant à préparer une loi qui sera
discuté dans le courant de l'année 2023
à propos d'échanges avec le Parlement
dont je respecte infiniment les
compétences
et le travail
nous n'avons pas du côté en dehors de la
voie professionnelle en prévision de loi
particulière parce que les capacités je
dirais
réglementaires du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
sont des capacités importantes comme
vous le savez monsieur le sénateur et
que par ailleurs les parlementaires ont
des missions également essentielles de
contrôle d'audition
auxquelles nous nous soumettons
évidemment très volontiers à propos des
langues régionales
il y a en effet des des échanges sur
notamment avec les parlementaires
Basques à propos de l'épreuve de
sciences du du brevet la question est en
étant étant discussion
à propos aussi donc des examens
nationaux mais c'est la question du
brevet qui a été posée ces temps-ci et à
propos également des écoles immersives
là-dessus la
position du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et que les familles doivent
pouvoir avoir une position un choix
raisonnable d'un point de vue pratique
entre des écoles offrant un enseignement
par exemple en langue basque et puis si
elle le souhaite et puis des écoles
offrant un enseignement en langue
française la possibilité du choix doit
être doit être préservé ma philosophie
générale c'est celle d'une ouverture
raisonnable à propos des langues
régionales j'y suis personnellement et
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le dire lors
de la précédente audition j'y suis très
ouvert j'ai pu mesurer d'ailleurs en
outre-mer
l'importance des classes
bil notamment parce que en outre-mer un
certain nombre d'élèves sont allophones
ne parlent pas français à l'entrée dans
la scolarisation et donc des classes
français créole leur permet d'apprendre
le français qui reste la prunelle de nos
yeux si je puis me permettre tout en
favorisant leur scolarisation et j'ai pu
assister à un cours
bilingue français créole réunionnais
dans un collège du quartier du Chaudron
le collège est divisait à Saint-Denis
qui était extrêmement intéressant et
j'ai pu constater à quel point les
élèves
via la langue créole progressait aussi
en français donc ça ne se les langues
régionales le développement des langues
régionales ne se fait pas à mon sens au
détriment de la langue française mais il
reste un certain nombre de questions en
particulier relatives au brevet et ce
sont des questions sur lesquelles nous
devons continuer à échanger
à propos madame la sénatrice Monnier à
propos du du pacte vous avez souligné
cette difficulté qu'il y a à travailler
plus vous avez fait allusion une note de
la dette qui indique que les enseignants
travaillent déjà beaucoup ce qui est
tout à fait j'en suis bien persuadé et
je ne serais pas celui qui
relativiserait le travail des
enseignants bien au contraire mais nous
avons également indiqué que dans les
nouvelles missions qui seront proposées
dans le cadre du Pacte il y aura des
missions que les enseignants remplissent
déjà y compris via des
impertes et variées et donc il faut
tenir compte aussi d'un éventail qui ne
viendra pas mécaniquement et de façon
purement
quantitative si vous voulez s'ajouter à
des tâches que les enseignants font déjà
mais nous devons progresser dans un
certain nombre de domaines que j'ai
indiqué il faut aussi tenir compte la
note le précise pas en tout cas de façon
très détaillée mais il faut aussi tenir
compte d'un travail enseignant qui peut
être variable selon les moments de la
vie
lorsque un enseignant est très
expérimenté il a il a bien entendu en
réserve si je peux dire des cours une
pratique professionnelle et donc des
une organisation et un emploi du temps
différent des enseignants
débutants nous devons tenir compte aussi
des de ces facteurs à propos des
suppressions de postes nous allons
poursuivre les dédoublements
actuellement à la rentrée 2022
les dédoublements en CP et CE1 sont en
repérer plus sont réalisés à 100% mais
ils ne sont pas réalisé à 100% en grande
section de maternelle je crois
qu'un sénateur ou une sénatrice qui a
fait allusion nous sommes à 75%, nous
serons à 86 % à la rentrée 2023 et nous
atteindrons les 100% à la rentrée 2024
donc nous avons d'ores et déjà prévu les
postes pour achever le dédoublement des
classes de grandes sections de
maternelle à la rentrée 2024 ça se fait
de façon échelonnée 75 86 100% c'est
tout à fait prioritaire pour nous vous
avez fait allusion au poste aux aesh
privé j'avoue avoir découvert cela dans
la presse peut-être comme vous c'est
ainsi donc nous enquêtons sur le sujet
mais je peux vous dire d'ores et déjà
que l'existence de ces h privé n'a
absolument pas mon approbation et ma
faveur et donc nous attendons d'abord de
voir ce qu'il en est précisément pour
pouvoir
intervenir de façon pertinente sur le
sujet en ce qui concerne la formation
des aesh l'enveloppe supplémentaire qui
a été
obtenu au titre d'une hausse de
rémunération prévoit un volant en fait
de
un volant concernant la la formation des
ash donc nous sommes très attentifs à la
formation des Ash et également à
l'enveloppe financière qui permettra de
les
d'assurer cette formation à propos
j'insiste sur ce point puisque je il y a
eu sans doute quelques
en dehors de cette enceinte des des
malentendus en particulier du côté de de
beaucoup d'enseignants la hausse de
rémunération prévue la hausse non
conditionnelle elle n'est pas prévue
seulement pour les enseignants néo
titulaires les enseignants qui entrent
dans le métier avec les 2000 euros net
par mois mais elle est prévue sur les à
peu près les 20 premières années de
carrière avec en particulier comme je
l'indiquais une notre objectif qui est
de remettre en cause le faux plat qui
est celui qui intervient une fois passé
les premières années d'augmentation
ensuite on est dans sur un faux plat de
grilles indiciaire qui est évidemment
très décourageant pour les enseignants
donc on réfléchit sur les 20 premières
années de carrière et puis en effet nous
réfléchissons aussi nous ferons des
propositions pour faciliter l'accès au
hors classe et à la classe exceptionnel
pour les fins de carrière j'ai noté à
cet égard ce que vous évoquiez à propos
de la sur-représentation des des hommes
dans le horlclass et la classe
exceptionnelle je
suis je vous suis volontiers madame la
sénatrice sur ce sujet même si cela
n'existe pas dans tous les corps et pas
à tout dans toutes les dans tous les
niveaux mais c'est un des points de
vigilance de de notre réflexion sur
l'égalité femme homme parce que il n'est
pas normal il n'est pas acceptable que
des
hommes soient
privilégiés disons dans l'accès au grade
élevé que ce soit en classe ou en classe
exceptionnelle
je poursuis si vous me permettez du côté
de madame la sénatrice billon à propos
donc de formation des aesh à propos
pardon d'éducation à la sexualité
puisque c'est un thème sur lequel nous
avons insisté d'abord parce que comme
vous l'avez souligné à juste titre il
faut respecter la loi celle du 4 juillet
2001 or nous avons lancé une enquête
flash qui indique qu'on est très loin de
ce que la loi
prescrit et à très juste titre et donc
nous avons
publié et mis en ligne un ensemble de
ressources pédagogiques que j'ai que
nous avons relu très très attentivement
ces ressources ont été mises en ligne il
y a plusieurs semaines
maintenant elles sont disponibles sur le
site Eduscol site de ressources très
complet avec des fiches prévues pour
chaque niveau de manière à faciliter la
relance si je puis dire de l'éducation à
la sexualité parce que on est loin du
compte comme l'enquête flash nous l'a
indiqué comme le rapport aussi de
l'inspection générale de l'année
dernière qui est également disponible en
ligne le soulignait et j'ai lu avec
intérêt le rapport que vous avez coécrit
sur la pornographie et je suis bien en
accord avec vous de ce point de vue là
il nous paraît que l'éducation axée
sexualité est absolument indispensable
pour l'égalité fille garçon femme homme
pour la réduction des violences sexistes
et sexuelle elle a elle offre énormément
davantage
une éducation à la sexualité bien menée
c'est aussi une manière de prévenir
j'allais dire des formes de violence ce
que j'ai appelé le virilisme dans les
cours de récréation si je puis utiliser
ce vocabulaire et puis en effet je
préfère que l'école s'occupe d'éducation
à la sexualité plutôt que l'industrie
pornographique pour le dire de façon un
peu rapide
et nous devons
là nous avons une mission qui est une
mission absolument essentielle et nous
allons veiller très attentivement à ceux
avec la ministre Isabelle Rome à ce que
l'éducation à la sexualité que la loi
soit soit respectée nous en faisons un
élément tout à fait important à propos
de médecine scolaire la question est
revenue à plusieurs reprises il faut
reconnaître que la médecine scolaire est
en crise je ne vous apprends rien les
postes de médecins scolaire sont des
postes vacants je pourrais doubler le
nombre de postes de médecins scolaires
ça ne changerait pas grand chose puisque
un bon tiers des postes de médecins sont
vacants voire plus dans certains
départements ruraux ou les médecins
scolaires sont devenus
extrêmement rares et ce en dépit des
hausses de rémunération des médecins
scolaires des deux catégories de
médecins scolaires les médecins dans qui
travaillent dans les établissements et
les médecins affectés dans les rectorats
ça ne suffit pas on a un problème
d'attractivité du métier les étudiants
en médecine choisissent peu la médecine
scolaire comme ils choisissent peu
d'ailleurs la médecine du travail qui
sont un peu en tout en bas dans les
choix effectués par les étudiants et
donc là on a un problème structurel je
rencontre à ce sujet le ministre de la
Santé demain pour évoquer cette question
et pour envisager une autre
structuration de la médecine scolaire
parce qu'on ne va pas recruter du jour
au lendemain les médecins scolaires qui
nous manquent je crois qu'il faut être
lucide à ce sujet et donc donc envisager
des alternatives qui permettent de
répondre aux impératifs de médecine de
de prévention et de détection puisqu'il
s'agit de cela la situation des
infirmiers et infirmières scolaires et
moins critiques et nous avons d'ailleurs
recruter et nous améliorons la situation
financière des infirmiers et infirmières
scolaires à propos des modules dédiés
maternels dans les inspects je crois que
c'est vous madame la sénatrice billon
qui posiez la question la question est
tout à fait juste parce que la formation
globalement des professeurs des écoles
de la petite section de maternelle
jusqu'au CM2 cette formation est
globalement la même
et donc il paraîtrait intéressant je
sais que ça suscite des débats donc ça
n'est pas une proposition fermée et
gravée dans le marbre mais il paraît
intéressant de de colorer en quelque
sorte de manière non non rigide puisque
il faut aussi imaginer ça existe bien
sûr des professeurs des écoles de
maternelle qui après quelques années
souhaitent passer du côté de l'école
élémentaire c'est cela doit être
préservé mais aussi des colorations pour
des formations à la petite enfance avec
des dimensions affectives psychologiques
qui sont un peu différents de ce que
l'on trouve à l'école élémentaire donc
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
réfléchissons mais la réflexion n'a pas
encore
abouti mais je serai ravi d'en reparler
avec vous à propos d'égalité fille
garçon puisque je mentionnais ce sujet
je sais votre
intérêt parfaitement légitime pour cela
et je me souviens madame la sénatrice de
la question que vous m'aviez posée il y
a il y a deux semaines à ce sujet on a
noté alors on a regardé d'un peu plus
près les chiffres on a noté
effectivement une baisse de 28% entre
2019 et 2021
en terminale du point de vue de la
spécialité maths et de la des maths
renforcée donc baisse de 28% du côté des
des filles un chiffre qui a été
d'ailleurs publié dans la presse mais on
sait on a regardé d'un peu plus près et
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
parallèlement une baisse de 22% du côté
des garçons
c'est 28 du côté des filles mais c'est
22%
et ça touche pas que les filles ça
touche pas que et donc l'écart il y a un
écart mais il est pas aussi
spectaculaire que celui
que celui qu'on pouvait imaginer
ce n'est pas pour moi une manière de
relativiser les choses mais je note un
problème plus général qui est celui des
disciplines scientifiques en notant
aussi quand même pour la pour le coup
pour relativiser c'est que entre la
classe de Première et la classe de
terminale les les élèves abandonnent une
des spécialités ils en ont trois en
première ils en ont deux en terminale il
est donc logique que entre la première
et la terminale on est une baisse
par suite de l'abandon d'une des
spécialités ça c'est vrai pour les
mathématiques mais ça n'est pas vrai que
pour les mathématiques à cause de la de
la réduction des spécialités il
n'empêche que nous avons un sujet qui
est le sujet de de la présence des
filles dans des disciplines qui sont
scientifiques je précise ce sont les
mathématiques ce sont les sciences de
l'ingénieur c'est le numérique alors que
du côté des SVT par exemple la situation
est tout à fait différente il y a donc
il y a du côté des du vivant du côté de
ce qui va aller du côté de la biologie
ce sont des disciplines au combien
importantes de nos jours de la médecine
la présence féminine là ne pose pas de
difficultés particulières mais du côté
des sciences de l'ingénieur pour prendre
un exemple très très évident là on a de
grosses difficultés et donc nous allons
faire plusieurs choses d'abord dans à
partir de la semaine prochaine à
l'occasion d'assises de mathématiques
qui ont lieu en début de semaine faire
un certain nombre de propositions mais
je tiens d'ores et déjà à vous dire
quelque chose c'est que pour moi la
seule
la seule
comment dirais-je le seul objectif
valable et légitime c'est 50% de filles
dans ces spécialités je ne vois pas
pourquoi on ne serait pas à égalité
grossièrement à égalité fille garçon
dans les disciplines du numérique des
sciences de l'ingénieur etc et c'est
l'objectif que nous devons atteindre et
nous allons faire des propositions assez
volontariste en la matière à l'occasion
de ces assises de mathématiques j'ai eu
l'occasion aussi d'en discuter très
récemment avec le tout récent
pardon prix
pardon à la médaille excusez-moi non pas
après
les prix Nobel en tête mais du côté des
mathématiques il n'y a pas de prix de
mail millionnaire France on a un grand
nombre 13 c'est tout à fait
impressionnant et
tout récent récipient d'air de la
médaille field
Hugo Dumesnil a accepté très très avec
beaucoup de générosité de de nous
accompagner et d'être en quelque sorte
ambassadeur des efforts que nous allons
mener il est très sensible à cette
question de l'égalité fille garçon il
est également très sensible à la
question plus généralement et nous
allons en parler la semaine prochaine de
la de ce que nous appelons la
réconciliation des élèves avec les
mathématiques il y a les élèves qui
choisissent la spécialité maths la
spécialité renforcée en terminale mais
il y a aussi les élèves hélas qui sont
dans une situation tout à fait précaire
en mathématiques en classe de seconde
comme les tests de position nous la
teste et nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire de cette situation et donc
nous allons travailler sur la place des
mathématiques au collège nous allons
faire les propositions la semaine
prochaine en ce sens et puis également
confirmer
la la la place des mathématiques dans le
tronc commun des élèves de Première là
aussi nous lorsque tous les calculs en
termes de poste seront fait nous ferons
les annonces ce sera fait donc la
semaine prochaine mais je fais de la
place des des filles des jeunes femmes
dans ces disciplines là avec ma collègue
Sylvie Retailleau une priorité absolue
c'est une question de justice on
pourrait dire mais c'est aussi une
question essentielle pour notre pays on
ne peut pas raisonnablement se priver de
la moitié de la population en tout cas
des talents considérables que Russell
par définition la moitié de la
population dans des disciplines
essentielles car nous d'ingénieurs nous
manquons de scientifiques de
spécialistes de questions tout à fait
essentielles donc c'est ce n'est pas
qu'une question de justice c'est une
question en réalité essentielle pour
notre pays
je voudrais dire un mot
sur les questions
relatives au
projet pédagogique puisque je crois que
c'est vous madame la sénatrice brûlin je
ne sais plus parlons excusez moi j'ai
encore du mal parfois à
mettre des noms sur les visages qui
évoquaient la question des critères à
propos des projets pédagogiques nous
venons justement de publier un guide il
est sorti hier ce guide à propos des
critères d'évaluation des projets
pédagogiques mais je veux vous assurer
que il ne s'agira pas d'une mise en
concurrence brutale des projets les uns
par rapport aux autres puisque le la
démarche sera d'accompagner les projets
pédagogiques dont la maturité ne sera
pas jugée suffisante de manière à ce que
ces projets puissent être représentés
dans un laps de temps raisonnable et
être validé à l'échelle des rectorat
donc les décisions se font effectivement
à l'échelle des rectorats en fonction de
la faisabilité de l'ambition des projets
pédagogiques et aussi mais aussi de leur
de la capacité à les évaluer puisque il
faut aussi pouvoir évaluer selon des
critères raisonnables les critères les
projets pédagogiques qui seront
présentés par les établissements
je voudrais dire un mot et je vous
promets que j'arrive à la fin de mon
intervention pardon président d'être un
peu long mais les questions que vous
posez sont essentielles
à propos madame la sénatrice casse bonne
de des enseignants de retour de
l'étranger je nous avons bien noté je
serai ravi d'en parler plus avec vous
c'est je me souviens d'une conversation
où vous m'aviez alerté au mois de
juillet sur cette question donc je vous
propose que nous échangions à ce sujet
je crois aussi que le ministère des
Affaires étrangères qui est aussi qui
compte aussi dans dans cette question
doit être mobilisée je voudrais dire
encore deux choses si vous me permettez
d'abord à propos des raz je crois que
c'est madame la sénatrice brûlin qui
posait la question donc il y a il doit y
avoir quelque chose comme 10000 380
postes de A à Z qui sont il y a une
hausse de ces dernières années
je n'ai pas d'état des lieux sur la
situation mais je serai je pense qu'il
est qu'il est temps de faire un point
sur la situation des Razet j'ai bien
noté votre votre point à ce à ce sujet
non je crois que c'était Madame De Marco
oui toutes mes excuses je finis par
fatiguer et je vais évoquer enfin la
question des activités physiques
quotidiennes en effet on est on est
entré dans la phase
d'obligation d'activer des 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidiennes dans
les écoles élémentaires après la une
première phase l'année dernière qui
était expérimentale et qui concernait
environ 9000 écoles là c'est l'ensemble
des écoles qui sont concernées on avait
d'abord dans en projet de fixé jusqu'à
la jusqu'aux vacances d'automne la mise
en place je dirais pratique de ces 30
minutes d'activités les réponses aux
questions qui pouvaient émerger ça et là
et donc il va être temps maintenant
puisque les vacances sont passées de
faire un premier point pour voir où l'on
en est de ces 30 minutes et quels sont
les types d'activité physique qui sont
proposées pour mémoire du côté des deux
heures de sport hebdomadaires dans les
collèges on est encore dans une phase
expérimentale puisque un peu plus de 200
collèges sont concernés pour cette année
par la phase
expérimentale
j'ai noté vos points à propos de des
prépas des classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles de commerce privé si j'ai
bien compris c'est je je vais regarder
cette question d'une manière générale la
question les classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles dont j'ai eu l'occasion
de de parler avec ma collègue Sylvie
retaillod puisque cette question
s'articule évidemment avec la question
des concours c'est une c'est une
question qui m'importe il faut aussi se
policiers des des élèves en classe
préparatoire et puis de petits signaux
d'alerte que l'on peut avoir du côté des
effectifs d'un certain nombre de ces
classes préparatoires j'en ai
j'en ai parfaitement conscience et puis
la question du décrochage scolaire que
vous évoquiez également le nombre de
décrocheurs scolaires c'est réduit ces
dernières années on était aux alentours
de 150 000 décrocheurs scolaires
il y a quelques années nous sommes
aujourd'hui à quelque chose comme 90 000
décrocheurs scolaires c'est 90 000 de
trop je vous le
concept très très volontiers mais nous
avons désormais une obligation à
respecter c'est l'obligation de
formation pour les élèves de pour les
jeunes gens de 16 à 18 ans et nous
devons respecter cette obligation de
formation pour ne laisser personne sur
le côté nous avons une grande réunion à
l'hôtel de Matignon avec la première
ministre avec des associations engagées
sur les questions de pauvreté qui nous
ont alerté sur les questions de
décrochage scolaires qui sont souvent
des questions liées à des situations de
grandes fragilités sociales de grandes
fragilités économiques il faut
reconnaître que nous n'avons pas encore
tous les outils du côté de l'éducation
nationale puisque c'est en dehors de
l'éducation nationale que c'est jeune se
situe pour le repérage et pour la le
rattrapage de ces jeunes en situation
difficile mais il est évident je vous
rejoins à ce sujet que c'est une
question essentielle alors j'ai encore
quelques questions je vais vous demander
parce qu'il est déjà à 19h35 passer
d'être vraiment très synthétique et
rapide dans votre expression pas
forcément de aborder une question qui a
déjà été posée au elle se Joseph
je vais très rapide puisque en fait
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre beaucoup de choses ont été
abordées donc c'était plus une façon
pour moi d'enfoncer un petit peu le clou
notamment sur l'attractivité du métier
du métier d'enseignant de relier aussi
un certain nombre de d'inquiétudes
notamment les incertitudes pour quelles
sont les personnels qui seraient
concernés la répartition le calendrier
mais beaucoup de choses ont été évoqués
donc notamment en particulier sur la
difficulté du recrutement et sur la
perspective déroulée de carrière ça a
été évoqué par un certain nombre de mes
de mes collègues voilà donc je veux pas
insister j'ai eu un grand nombre de
réponses merci merci Sabine Drexler
oui monsieur le ministre alors en 2020
j'ai interrogé Madame Nathalie et limace
qui était alors auditionnée par notre
commission en tant que secrétaire d'État
à l'éducation prioritaire celle-ci était
alors une priorité du quinquennat du
président de la République
aujourd'hui alors que la crise sanitaire
les confinements sont passés par là il
n'y a plus de secrétariat d'État à
l'éducation prioritaire mais toujours
voir davantage d'inégalités scolaire
alors à l'époque aux côtés de
l'Association des mers ruraux de France
et des parents ne regrettions le manque
d'impact de cette politique en milieu
rurale et le fait que les dédoublements
de classe dans les reps iraient plus non
seulement ne les concernait pas mais qui
se faisait au détriment de leur
territoire qui subissaient de nombreuses
fermetures de classe voire d'école
parfois dans des sites isolés
contraignant les enfants à parcourir des
kilomètres pour être scolarisé madame
elimas nous a dit avoir réalisé suite à
son tour de France de l'éducation
prioritaire l'ampleur des besoins en
termes d'enseignants dans les écoles en
milieu rural et nous avait alors annoncé
vouloir expérimenter une nouvelle
approche qui tiennent davantage compte
des écarts existants entre la ruralité
et la ville alors en 2021
l'expérimentation
victoire éducatif ruraux a été lancé
dans plusieurs académies pour tenter de
mieux prendre en considération les
besoins de ces territoires pourriez-vous
nous faire un point sur ce dispositif
sera-t-il généralisé à toutes les
académies et si oui à quelle date et
nous dire également quels sont et quels
seront compte tenues de l'éloignement de
ces territoires des structures médicaux
psychopédagogiques les moyens mis en
oeuvre actuellement et durant votre
mandat pour accompagner les situations
individuelles difficiles de plus en plus
nombreuses et celle dite ingérable qui
laisse les enseignants démunis dans ses
territoires merci Elsa chalk je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre alors il a beaucoup été
question du manque d'attractivité du
métier de professeur et j'aimerais
prolonger ce constat en vous
interrogeant sur le manque criant de
professeurs d'allemand dans notre pays
il ressort notamment que 72% des postes
n'étaient pas pourvu à la dernière
rentrée ce qui engendre inévitablement
des conséquences en termes
d'apprentissage pour les élèves mais
également en termes en fait de
conditions de travail pour les
professeurs d'allemand alors cette
pénurie on le sait concerne tout le pays
mais elle est particulièrement marquée
en Alsace alors même qu'il existe une
demande de plus en plus forte à la fois
de la part des parents mais également
des élus pour pouvoir bénéficier d'un
cursus bilingue et un cursus bilingue en
fait tout au long de la scolarité donc
cette situation a conduit des
associations mais également des
collectivités à prendre des initiatives
à l'instar notamment de la collectivité
européenne d'Alsace qui finance par
exemple à hauteur de plus d'un million
d'euros une indemnité spécifique pour
enseignant du premier degré intervenant
en allemand en classe en voie bilingue
mais malgré cela le problème persiste et
même il s'accentue et je je prends ici
les propos du recteur de l'académie de
Strasbourg qui indiquait que le problème
chronique de recrutement devient même un
facteur de blocage donc le déficit de
professeur d'allemand est réellement
très préoccupant car on le sait
l'enseignement des langues étrangères
essentielles pour notre jeunesse pour
l'ensemble de nos jeunes bien évidemment
que parler anglais c'est une chose qui
est nécessaire mais dans une région
transfrontalière comme l'Alsace
maîtriser la langue justement du pays
voisin c'est également une nécessité qui
ouvre également de grandes opportunités
au niveau professionnel et là aussi les
chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes puisque
alors que 600 000 élèves apprenaient
l'allemand à l'école en première langue
en 1995 dans notre pays ce chiffre est
passé à 147 000 en 2021
et on le voit dans l'article 10 du
traité d'Aix-la-Chapelle de 2019
il a été pris un engagement des États à
développer l'apprentissage mutuel de la
langue de l'autre pays et justement à
l'heure où nous évoquons le budget 2023
pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre quel sera justement la
mobilisation de votre ministère pour
répondre à ce qui est une véritable
urgence ce besoin de recrutement de
professeurs d'allemand mais également
justement la nécessité d'inciter les
jeunes à apprendre l'allemand je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir sur deux points
notre rapporteur Jacques gros Perrin a
parlé de crise de recrutement vous-même
avez parlé de perte d'attractivité mais
vous avez aussi rappelé que la priorité
de votre gouvernement était de la
revalorisation des enseignants
financiers des enseignants avec le
comptant sur un engagement sans faille
des enseignants et et qui sont pas
rétribués à votre à votre avis à sa
juste valeur mais cette revalorisation
passe aussi par la reconnaissance du
travail des enseignants or quand je vous
écoute on dirait qu'il y a pas de
problème et lorsqu'on ne revient sur le
terrain et qu'on est confronté à la
réalité des choses qu'est-ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui nous avons mangé sur
le département dans lequel je suis les
élus des titulaires du CAPES qui ont un
niveau bac + 5 qui depuis 5 ans n'ont
toujours pas de poste malgré plusieurs
demandes chaque année alors ils font des
remplacements de quelques mois par
rapport à et je vois les personnes que
j'ai interrogées pour certaines depuis
septembre 2022 un seul remplacement de
quelques semaines et actuellement ils
sont sans poste et dans le même temps
des contractuels à bac + 3 ont été qui
ont été peut-être des formations rapides
eux on déposent de remplacement donc il
est un petit peu incompréhensible que
revaloriser et mettre en avant les
enseignants c'est bien sûr l'aspect
financier mais aussi c'est les mettre
devant des élèves pour faire leur
travail et leur mission sur lesquelles
ils sont ils ont été formés et
aujourd'hui il y a rien de pire pour les
enseignants qui sont titulaires de ce
capesse avec bac + 5 d'attendre encore
aujourd'hui un poste pour être face aux
élèves ça c'est ma première question
qu'en est-il de cette situation et
comment résoudre ce problème deuxième
question est et là je reprends les
propos de mon collègue Bernard fieller
vous avez répondu c'était sur la
question des 30 minutes à l'école alors
là aussi avant de venir en séance
aujourd'hui on est j'ai interrogé ces
dernières semaines un certain nombre de
directeurs et directrices d'école pour
savoir vraiment été appliqués ces 30
minutes je peux vous dire le ministre
vous avez du travail parce que c'est
entre 10 et 20% ou c'est appliqué et
donc lorsqu'on sait que c'est une
obligation qui vous donnez de nous
rappeler que c'est une obligation dans
la loi et que ça doit être appliqué à
partir du mois de vacances qui arrivent
il faut faire passer l'information au
directeur et directrice d'école parce
que ce n'est pas appliqué au très mal
appliqué il y a un deuxième sujet molle
sur lequel je voudrais avoir aussi votre
position c'est le savoir nager c'est une
obligation aujourd'hui dans l'école de
pour les enseignants d'amener des
enfants à la pratique de la natation la
découverte de la natation lorsqu'on sait
qu'il y a plus de 400 noyades par an
d'enfants de moins de 6 ans et
aujourd'hui carne est-il aujourd'hui il
serait intéressant que vous nous fassiez
un bilan mais un vrai bilan un bilan
réel de la situation de la pratique de
ces activités qui sont importants en
termes de sécurité mais aussi sur le
plan de la de la santé pour lutter
contre les sédentarité donc voilà les 30
minutes sont pas appliquées aujourd'hui
c'est clair et le savoir nager est mal
appliqué
Olivier Pacaud merci monsieur le
Président deux points aussi d'abord dans
la lignée de skyvoquer Sabine Drexler la
problématique de la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire plus exactement de la carte
des inégalités de l'éducation
prioritaire vous avez abordé ce sujet
devant les députés monsieur le ministre
et vous avez concédé je vous cite que la
carte l'éducation prioritaire a en
particulier que vous devez procéder aux
ajustements nécessaires votre
prédécesseur nous a dit la même chose
pendant 5 ans et rien n'a été fait si ce
n'est les expérimentations des contrats
locaux d'accompagnement et les fameux
territoires éducatifs ruraux dans le
budget 2023 il y a 9 millions d'euros
qui sont fléchés vers ça 9 millions
d'euros sur 59 milliards
objectivement je vais pas vous faire
l'insulte de vous faire le calcul mais
c'est pas une priorité c'est le moins
con puisse dire et quand on sait que
70% des enfants qui relèveraient
l'éducation prioritaire ni pas
c'est insupportable et ça fait 6 ans que
ça dure
c'est insupportable deuxième point
qui concerne l'inclusion mais alors une
inclusion particulière
c'est l'inclusion non pas des enfants
qui présentent un handicap moteur ou un
retard cognitif c'est l'inclusion des
enfants qui présentent des troubles du
comportement et vous l'avez plus ou
moins abordé monsieur le ministre en
parlant d'une marée de d'élèves qui sont
entre guillemets orientés par les IME ou
plutôt par les MDPH parce qu'il n'y a
plus à cette place dans les IME bon il y
a 4000 nouveaux aesh qui vont arriver
les aesh ne sont pas des éducateurs
spécialisés les enseignants ne sont pas
des éducateurs spécialisés et ces
enfants qui présentent des troubles du
comportement malheureusement ils ne sont
pas à leur place dans des classes
traditionnelles tout à l'heure Jacques
gros Perrin a évoqué la problématique
des démissions moi j'aimerais bien
savoir le nombre de démissions liées
justement à l'inclusion de ces enfants
qui qui sont malheureusement de gros
perturbateurs qui sont très malheureux
dans ces classes qui rendent les petits
camarades très malheureux
qui deviennent pour les professeurs et
les aesh qui doivent les gérer un
problème insoluble ce n'est pas du tout
abordé dans la problématique budgétaire
et je termine par là
Céline Brulin évoqué vous a demandé s'il
y avait éventuellement des liens avec le
ministère de la Santé peut-être des
collectivités territoriales la vraie
problématique c'est qu'il y a pas assez
d'imme il y a pas assez d'ITEP mais
est-ce que il y a une volonté de votre
côté de pousser ce sujet c'est le seul
moyen de vraiment insérer ces gamins qui
en ont besoin
Stéphane piennois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous comprendrais avec la
multiplicité des interventions et la
longueur des réponses que vous apportez
d'ailleurs à quel point les sujets liés
à l'éducation nationale nous nous
tiennent à cœur vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos liminaire la crise des
vocations en disant à la fois que ce
n'est pas nouveau la cause n'est
évidemment pas seulement le salaire qui
est
reconnu comme relativement bas
relativement faible et donc l'effet de
l'attention aussi sur le marché du
travail fait qu'aujourd'hui de plus en
plus on choisit de faire d'autres
métiers et pas seulement pour ce salaire
et donc comme nous vous avez
probablement des retours de terrain
comme nous vous avez des témoignages qui
remontent de la des établissements
scolaires et des enseignants pour vous
dire qu'en fait ce sont les conditions
d'exercice qui sont à pointer et
notamment
le retour ou le manque d'autorité le
respect aussi de la laïcité ma première
question c'est quel moyen met-on
vraiment sur ces deux points pour que
les enseignants soient véritablement des
enseignants et non pas des
officiers de police judiciaire parfois
sur l'enseignement moral et civique j'ai
présidé l'année dernière une mission
d'information sur la façon de
redynamiser la culture citoyenne en
particulier chez les jeunes suite à
l'abstention qui avait été constaté sur
les sur les élections le rapport le
rapporteur de cette mission
enric-emmanuel cherche à vous joindre je
crois et obtenir un rendez-vous pour
vous présenter les résultats de nos
travaux de nos conclusions mais je me
permets de me focaliser sur un axe
particulier celui donc de l'éducation
morale et civique c'est un véritable
parcours citoyen qui est inscrit dans le
code de l'éducation dans nos programmes
mais qui en réalité n'atteint pas ses
objectifs la faute à des à des
programmes justement pléthoriques à un
enseignement un horaire très faible et à
des ressources insuffisantes alors je
fais le lien avec le fond d'innovation
pédagogique que vous vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure à hauteur de 150 millions
d'euros dans nos auditions dans les
auditions que nous avons menées dans
cette mission les enseignants nous
disaient manqué de ressources
pédagogiques est-ce qu'il est
envisagez-vous pour fournir aux
enseignants des documents nécessaires à
cet enseignement sans faire appel par
exemple pour reprendre un article de
presse paru aujourd'hui donc sans faire
appel au la diffusion en classe de vidéo
assez peu pédagogiques d'une association
militante sur le bien-être animal je
continue sur le la formation
scientifique globalement de nos
enseignants du premier degré et plus
globalement du niveau académique en
mathématiques de nos élèves qui sortent
de l'enseignement secondaire j'ai pas
bien compris quels étaient vos mesures
pour remédier à ce niveau
d'une part de nos enseignants et d'autre
part pour renforcer la place des
mathématiques
au lycée j'ai bien entendu qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui se ramait sur le
collège éventuellement si on peut être
concerté consulté on y répondra très
favorablement dernière question les
contractuels ça rejoint d'ailleurs un
peu la question qui a été posée tout à
l'heure on a des besoins de remplacement
qui ne sont pas pourvus alors que on
rentre d'embauche des contractuels avec
des entretiens très rapides des
formations très rapides j'ose vous
rappeler qu'il y a des d'abord des
personnalités remplaçants qui n'ont pas
de poste et deuxièmement des des
candidats qui sont seulement admissibles
qui n'ont pas réussi leur concours
parfois qui sont bi-admissibles et
peut-être qu'on peut faire appel à eux
de manière prioritaire pour effectuer
ses remplacements je vous remercie
et enfin la dernière intervenante Sonia
de la pauvreté qui s'est engagée à faire
une intervention courte
[Rires]
merci monsieur le Président de me donner
la parole monsieur le ministre donc
quelques questions la première porte sur
l'éducation artistique et culturelle et
la fameuse par collective du Pass
Culture
on a eu un certain nombre d'auditions
notamment dans le cadre du budgets
culture qui nous ont alertés sur le
fonctionnement de cette part collective
et les risques de sa mise en oeuvre
notamment le fait que il brise un peu le
cercle vertueux qui était on réalise un
projet pédagogique et on regarde dans
l'interaction hypotheritoire les acteurs
culturels du territoire
ce qui peut permettre de mettre en
oeuvre ce projet pédagogique là en
l'occurrence c'est un embouteillage dans
les appels à candidature et à
labellisation et on est dans une espèce
de grande boutique tous les porteurs de
projet culturels proposent hors cadre
finalement d'un projet pédagogique tout
un tas d'activités aux écoles et donc on
est dans un une espèce de dérapage
mercantile donc outre l'embouteillage je
pense qu'il est important de remettre de
l'ordre un peu dans le fonctionnement de
cette fameuse par collective ma deuxième
question porte sur les classes ça aurait
aménagé les fameuses Cham Chad et puis
les classes sportives dans un certain
nombre d'établissements du secondaire
les dotations horaires ont été
banalisées dans le cas de la dotation
horaires globale ce qui est un risque
finalement en ajustant
la disponibilité horaires des
enseignants de faire disparaître ces
enseignements spécialisés ces classes
qu'on a trop souvent décrié comme étant
élitiste et qui en réalité quand on
réussit à ne pas les rendre élitistes
sont une véritable chance une
opportunité pour tout un tas de jeunes
qui voient des possibilités de
développer leurs compétences dans des
domaines artistiques et sportifs ma
troisième question porte sur les assises
du numérique et cette fameuse formation
des formateurs au numérique qu'on avait
réussi à arracher dans le cadre de la
loi pour l'école de la confiance et ma
collègue Catherine Morin de saillie qui
qui m'a suggéré cette question où en
est-on du bilan de la formation des
formateurs au numérique parce que on a
quand même traversé finalement une
époque à l'époque de la covid qui était
censée nous amener sur des sur des
enseignements plutôt de nature mixte en
tout cas très modernisée et très nouveau
et on reste encore sur un fonctionnement
éducatif qui reste peu numérique ou
au travers d'ateliers informatiques mais
pas dans la façon finalement de
transmettre de transmettre la pédagogie
et les enseignements aux jeunes et ma
dernière question de porte effectivement
sur la forme d'éducation prioritaire
comme étant intervenu ma collègue
Sabrine Rissler vous avez évoqué qu'il
était temps de faire un bilan sur les
razèdes très clairement on a eu un débat
sur cette réforme on n'a pas d'état des
lieux on a élargi le cadre et on s'est
toujours pas où on en je vous remercie
voilà
merci
monsieur le Président encore une belle
brassée de questions et je vous en
remercie très très sincèrement
alors je vais commencer par cette
question importante soulevée par madame
la sénatrice Drexler à propos du milieu
rural pour
vous vous indiquez que
d'abord deux choses la
la situation des écoles rurales du point
de vue des résultats scolaires et
favorables la le problème qui a été
soulevé et je reviendrai à ce qui a été
mis en place même de manière imparfaite
c'est plutôt du côté du monde rural de
bons résultats scolaires mais des
ambitions scolaires et et de poursuivre
d'études plus limitées et donc on a une
c'est la caractéristique de de des
écoles et des collèges du primaire et du
secondaire en milieu rural mais le
développement des classes enfin de
l'éducation prioritaire de type prep+ ne
se fait pas au détriment du des écoles
rurales
il y a eu ces dernières années le
développement assez vif des territoires
éducatifs ruraux il y en a 67 en cette
rentrée 2022 avec pour 2023 un budget
qui est prévu à l'appui de ces
territoires économiques de ces
territoires
éducatifs ruraux
ce développement a été très fort ces
dernières années il nous faut
j'en ai lu des comptes rendus qui
pouvaient être variables selon ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux donc il
nous faut faire un bilan de ces de ces
TER pour voir où on en est ce sont un
peu les terres ce sont c'est un peu
l'équivalent des cités éducatives en
fait dans du côté
urbain et les cités éducatives elles
fonctionnent bien il y en a plus de 200
maintenant qui existent un peu partout y
compris d'ailleurs dans les outre-mer il
reste à en tirer un à faire un bilan de
du pendant du côté rural avec les
territoires éducatifs ruraux qui ont la
le même objectif c'est à dire créer des
constellations
écoles collèges lycée avec
éventuellement du post-bac et également
du rapprochement entre
du scolaire du périscolaire et de
l'extrascolaire et une attention c'est
la différence principale je dirais avec
les cités éducatives une attention
portée au transport à la question des
transports scolaires qui est une
question importante et nous avons eu
quelques surfrodes
à propos des transports scolaires à la
rentrée
je pense et je vous suis volontiers là
dessus si tel votre
pensée qu'il importe de faire un premier
bilan de faire un premier bilan de ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux
en ce qui concerne les fermetures de
classe que vous avez évoqué il est
évident que des fermetures de classe ou
que la baisse démographique dans des
territoires ruraux éventuellement isolés
ne peut pas être appréhendé de la même
manière que dans le centre de Paris qui
connaît aussi une baisse démographique
importante des effectifs scolaires ça
nous en sommes bien persuadés et il est
hors de question de soumettre à la même
règle arithmétique tous les territoires
en particulier dans des zones qui sont
des zones isolées
madame la sénatrice Schalke la question
des professeurs d'allemand je l'ai
évoqué incidemment en parlant du
rendement très faible du concours de
capes et d'agrégation d'allemand c'est
nous avons un souci de recrutement très
important en ce qui concerne les
professeurs
d'allemand et c'est un souci de
recrutement qui est à la fois parallèle
mais qui est très accentué par rapport à
des effectifs
scolaires pour ce qui concerne
l'apprentissage de l'allemand qui ces
dernières années s'effrent tout en
restant aux alentours on est aux
alentours de 15% je crois que c'est
14,6% à l'échelle du pays mais avec des
variations régionales importantes il va
de soi que dans les régions frontalières
dans l'Est de la France Alsace Lorraine
mais aussi Franche-Comté ça je parle
sous le contrôle du sénateur gros Perrin
la présence de la langue allemande est
importante je me suis entretenu à ce
sujet avec l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne
puisque
c'est un souci important et d'autre part
la situation de la langue française en
Allemagne et globalement similaire et
donc nous avons de quoi changer
là-dessus c'est un sujet qui est au menu
du Conseil des ministres franco-allemand
qui je crois va se tenir au mois de
janvier prochain et d'ici là nous aurons
mis au point une et proposer une
stratégie pour répondre aux difficultés
que vous avez soulignées et qui sera
rendu public à la fin de l'année 2022
avant le Conseil des ministres
franco-allemand sachez que c'est tout à
fait nous sommes tout à fait conscients
des difficultés à la fois de recrutement
mais aussi de l'importance de la langue
allemande à tous égards et l'ambassadeur
n'a pas manqué de de souligner l'intérêt
et l'importance de la langue allemande
et pas simplement pour des raisons je
dirais culturelles mais aussi pour des
raisons économiques de relations avec
notre principal partenaire économique à
propos de
je crois que c'était monsieur le
sénateur Savin qui posiez la question
alors je vais regarder d'un peu plus
près le cas que vous soulignez à propos
de l'Isère je suppose
il n'est pas toujours anormal d'avoir
des situations de TZR si c'est à cela
que vous pensez qui soit des enseignants
un peu expérimentés parce que le
remplacement demande une certaine
expérience dans le fait de saisir
à de façon direct et de remplacer
rapidement un collègue qui ne peut plus
assurer son enseignement donc le fait
qu'il y ait des enseignants expérimentés
qui soient remplaçant n'est pas
nécessairement une
quelque chose qui est antithétique si
vous voulez des politiques menées par
les rectorats mais nous allons regarder
cela et vous faire une réponse précise
pour ceux qui concerne ce à quoi vous
faites allusion dans votre département
de l'Isère les 30 minutes je vous
remercie de l'enquête que vous avez
menée petite enquête et donc on va quand
même regarder d'un peu plus près je me
permets simplement je ne remet pas en
cause votre enquête bien entendu je je
me permets d'assurer simplement
d'attirer votre attention sur le fait
que ces 30 minutes peuvent prendre des
formes assez différentes selon les
établissements c'est pas forcément 30
minutes en continu ça peut être deux
fois 15 minutes ça peut prendre la
récréation il y a d'où l'intérêt de
faire le point et de voir où on en est
du point de vue des dispositifs qui ont
été mises en place dans les écoles
élémentaires pour assurer ces 30 minutes
je vous suis volontiers là-dessus du
côté du savoir nager il y a quand même
une progression puisque les attestations
du savoir nager on était à 60000 il y a
quelques années l'objectif pour 2022
c'est 90
000 attestations savoir nager nous avons
un objectif très ambitieux en vue des
Jeux Olympiques qui est de passer à 400
000 savoirs nager pour 2024 pour l'année
des Jeux Olympiques c'est une ambition
très importante mais qui dépend aussi
d'un facteur que nous n'avons pas sous
la main si je puis dire c'est-à-dire
l'équipement en piscine il y a un lien
direct j'avais moi-même mené un petit
travail de recherche donc cette question
m'intéresse tout à fait sur le savoir
nager et on n'apprend pas à nager dans
la mer et donc il n'y a aucune relation
entre le littoral et le fait de savoir
nager marseille est une ville par
exemple où le taux d'enfant qui nage
savent nager est un et bas alors qu'on
pourrait penser évidemment le contraire
le lien c'est la présence des piscines
et il y a des municipalités où les
piscines manquent pour le dire pardon
excusez-moi et tout à fait donc à la
fois une question de rénovation des
fameux programme des 1000 piscines qui
avaient été ouvert à la fin des années
60-70 avec des architectures d'ailleurs
tout à fait
intéressantes j'ai eu l'occasion de d'en
voir dans la région de Rouen récemment
donc à la question de la rénovation de
ces piscines qui ont maintenant 50 ans
et puis il y a la question aussi de
l'équipement en piscine dans des villes
qui ont vu leur piscine fermée ou qui
sont mal équipés en piscine ça il y a
aucun doute à ce sujet à propos de la
carte de l'éducation prioritaire
monsieur le sénateur Paco je vous
confirme que notre ambition s'est bien
de retoucher la carte de l'éducation
prioritaire puisque cette carte remonte
à 2015 et elle est fondée sur des
données qui remontent à 2011 donc en
réalité cette carte elle est assise d'un
point de vue sociologique je dirais sur
des données qui ont une dizaines
d'années ce qui compte tenu de
l'évolution assez rapide d'un certain
nombre de centres urbains fait que cette
carte en effet doit être retouchée je
sais que
Jean-Michel Blanquer c'était engagé à
regarder les choses un effort avec je
crois commencer d'être entrepris et je
crois aussi que la crise sanitaire a
paralyser les choses mais c'est un
chantier que nous devons reprendre il y
a de quoi actualiser la carte de
l'éducation prioritaire c'est tout à
fait évident je vous suis très
volontiers et je peux vous garantir que
nous allons mener à bien ce chantier qui
est un chantier délicat puisque bien sûr
les oppositions les collectivités
peuvent
ne pas être toujours
coopérative les parents d'élèves aussi
les enseignants aussi on entre sur des
terrains qui sont parfois des terrains
délicats je crois qu'il faut s'attaquer
à l'éducation prioritaire il faut
pouvoir sortir des établissements qui ne
correspondent plus à l'éducation
pruditaire du et puis en faire rentrer
d'autres bien entendu pour l'instant on
est dans un dans un modèle assez
statique pour le dire assez vite je vous
suis alors sur les 9 millions auxquels
vous faites allusion pour l'éducation
priodaire c'est pas 9 millions pour
l'éducation prioritaire en France c'est
pour les territoires éducatifs ruraux on
est bien d'accord on est à peine à 9
millions on doit être à 8,6 de moyenne
quelque chose comme cela
regardons d'abord où on en est avec ces
territoires éducatifs ruraux j'ai je
viens dans parler et j'ai bien noté
votre point il est certain que il y a
des il faut reconnaître que l'école
inclusive c'est une démarche extrêmement
positive et dont nous devons je crois à
l'échelle du ministère de l'éducation
nationale être fier depuis 2005 depuis
la loi de 2005 et puis il y a eu
accélération de l'école inclusive ces
dernières années cela est un acquis
important et en même temps il faut aussi
reconnaître que tous les enfants ne
peuvent pas être en milieu ordinaire et
donc nous avons l'existence des
instituts médicaux-éducatifs du
médico-éducatif et de mon point de vue
ne doit pas être remise en cause il y a
des il y a des relations il y a des
agrafages si je peux dire entre
ime et puis milieu ordinaire ça se fait
sous forme expérimentale dans un certain
nombre de régions mais
l'école inclusive doit aussi
disons que le dispositif l'éventail des
des dispositions doit aussi faire de
telle sorte que des enfants
présentant des besoins très spécifiques
puissent être accueillis en du milieu
ordinaire ça je vous suis volontiers
là-dessus et j'évoquais la situation
d'embolie générale à laquelle nous
faisons face et qui nécessitent que nous
échangions et je vous confirme les
échanges que nous avons et je vais
continuer à le faire dans les mois et
dans les semaines à venir avec mes
collègues Braun et Darius sec avec les
MDPH j'ai reçu les représentants des
MDPH au mois de juillet pour évoquer ces
questions d'ailleurs nous étions assez
en phase sur le constat et sur la
nécessité de de réfléchir sur cette
question de manière un peu structurelle
et
de ne pas se contenter si je puis dire
d'ajouter des postes de daesh qui de
toute façon ne suffisent pas bien
entendu même s'il faut créer des postes
d'Ash je pense que c'est c'est c'est
très important mais il faut aussi
réfléchir un peu structurellement c'est
pourquoi j'ai parlé d'acte de de l'école
inclusive et puis pardon pardon
président d'être un peu un peu long je
vais accélérer pour j'ai bien noté
monsieur le sénateur votre point je
crois que c'est monsieur le sénateur
pied-noir c'est ça excusez-moi votre
point sur le MC et sur le manque de
ressources pédagogique si j'ai bien
compris nous avons
mis ou somme sur le point de mettre à
disposition de nouvelles ressources
pédagogiques donc je me permettrai de
vous faire une réponse un peu plus
complète par écrit lorsque j'aurai un
peu précisé les choses du côté de l'EMC
le bien-être animal
c'est une question après tout et
j'observe j'en ai parlé il y a
[Musique]
vraiment on a on a été on a été très
actif de ce côté là mais nous avons dû
aussi faire appel
au-delà des des listes complémentaires à
d'autres enseignants contractuels quant
aux mathématiques j'ai évoqué la
question de leur ennemi de mathématiques
dans le tronc commun de première et j'ai
évoqué aussi la tenue des assises
mathématiques la semaine prochaine qui
sera l'occasion de parler de
mathématiques en première en seconde
mais aussi au collège et donc je me
permets ça n'est pas je me permets de
vous faire patienter un peu mais nous
allons avancer et j'ai mentionné le fait
que le la récente médailles Hugo du
Mesnil avait accepté de nous accompagner
et de nous représenter comme ambassadeur
des mathématiques pour l'année prochaine
et il sera très très actif à propos du
Pass Culture j'ai bien noté madame la
sénatrice votre point ce que je sais
d'ores et déjà c'est que le Pass Culture
collectif rencontre un très grand succès
il y a un démarrage extrêmement
spectaculaire des sorties culturelles en
cette rentrée en compensation peut-être
en rattrapage aussi des difficultés que
nous avons connues ces dernières années
en l'espace d'un mois les le Pass les
sorties équivales à plusieurs mois de
l'année dernière dans les proportions
tout à fait importante
ça ce sont les chiffres vous faites
allusion plutôt à des aspects
qualitatifs si j'ai bien compris
je vais en parler avec ma collègue
ministre de la Culture mais d'ores et
déjà je me félicite du succès rencontré
par le Pass Culture collectif ça
représente environ 800 euros par classe
à peu près et je me permets aussi
d'ajouter que l'éducation artistique et
culturelle comme vous le savez
évidemment ne se résume pas ou pas cette
culture nous avons également l'éducation
artistique et culturelle est également
très importante je vais nous allons
prendre des initiatives en la matière
dans les mois à venir dans le primaire
comme dans le secondaire à propos de
bilan de formation au numérique alors il
y a les donc les les territoires
numériques éducatifs qui sont encore
proposés sous une forme expérimentale et
de mémoire je crois qu'il y a 12
départements c'est cela 12 départements
cette année qui sont des départements
expérimentaux dont le Doubs d'ailleurs
où j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre il y
a quelques mois et le Doubs est un très
très bon exemple d'un territoire
numérique éducatif qui articule non
seulement les questions accès à Internet
y compris dans des zones un peu isolées
mais aussi les questions d'offres
éducatives de liens entre l'école et les
élèves du type de ressources
pédagogiques que l'on trouve d'éducation
médias à l'information pour prévenir les
élèves en ce qui concerne l'utilisation
de leur donner personnelle en
particulier sur les réseaux sociaux donc
les la réponse provisoire que je vous
ferai ce sont ces cette expérience des
territoires numériques éducatifs j'ai
bien noté également le point que vous
soulevez à propos des charmes des
classes sportives
et de danse donc Cham musique danse et
puis d'autres formats de ce genre et des
questions de réduction d'horaires si
j'ai bien compris on va vous répondre là
un peu précisément parce que je ne sais
pas exactement en fait il y a des
horaires qui ont été dégagées pour
aménager le temps de scolarité pour
pouvoir accéder à ces formations
particulières ces enseignements
particuliers et en fait les dotations
horaires sont banalisées dans le sein de
la au sein de la DSG et du coup le
risque est grand pour des problèmes
d'arbitrage et d'organisation des
enseignements de voir une part de ses
horaires spécifiques de ces
enseignements spécifiques ce ou diminuer
ou se dégrader très bien j'ai pris bonne
note je vous en remercie et nous allons
regarder cela il vous répondre par écrit
si vous me le permettez voilà monsieur
le Président merci monsieur je crois que
l'agrégation épreuve que vous connaissez
bien les l'oral durent 6h il y en a
plusieurs on n'y est pas encore mais on
s'en rapproche vous voyez quand vous
venez au Sénat en tout cas merci la
précision de vos réponses où vous avez
vu que les questions sont nombreuses on
a été aussi attentifs au fait que vous
alliez faire des annonces de la semaine
prochaine donc nous écouterons avec
beaucoup d'intérêt les annonces que vous
ferez la semaine prochaine merci
monsieur le Président merci merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
été vraiment très très heureux de
d'échanger avec vous et je suis à votre
disposition merci beaucoup